there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock he out there in YouTube land
it's the 13 o'clock podcast episode 164
yeah oh [ __ ] I forgot to bring Dennis
yeah where's Dennis microphone there in
case he wants to say something into it
yeah okay dams Raiders yeah he's much
smaller than I thought yeah all right
what did you show today so episode 164
as I said during the month of October I
thought I would kind of do more sort of
variety shows but based more around like
a horror type of theme so on this
particular episode I decided to do five
cases of poisoners okay so this is gonna
be kind of like that last show where we
have a bunch of different topics on yeah
I mean they're all poisoners but it's
like different cases stuff like that and
again this was something that because a
couple of these serial killers have been
recommended to me by listeners than I
thought that it would be good to like
kind of lump them all on one show even
though obviously there are way more
poisoners that I can put on the show
Florence Maybrick dr. Crippen people
like that but the five I picked were
ones that were recommended and ones that
I found particularly interesting for cuz
for some reason it's like it's
fascinating you know I'm fascinated by
crime and serial killers and stuff like
in general but for some reason I'm like
really really fascinated by poisoners
I'm not trying to know why it's a woman
thing not necessarily
know that we're doing about two of these
or women and three of them are men well
actually one of them they don't know if
it's a man or woman because they didn't
call them but uh you know what I mean
but this is yes always good cases yeah
but they don't stick out to me in my
mind is particularly horrible they're
cruel yeah but they're not they're not
like real violent well it's usually
because people that resort to poison
it's usually for practical purposes like
it's they want to get rid of a spouse or
they want to collect life insurance or
they want to do something that Roxy me
yeah stuff like that so it's not quite
as like splashy or gruesome I guess but
I think something that I always found
kind of fascinating about it was I guess
because I love like all that like
old-timey
like kind of Victorian imagery of like
old apothecary shops and stuff like that
so just like reminds me of that so maybe
that's why I'm kind of fascinated by it
but look look at you guys I have I
bought this at Barnes & Noble like a
long time ago this is why my ex has me
used to worry about me because I books
like this and I'm like oh you might need
to know something when you're writing a
book okay well yeah that's what that's
that's the excuse I always get for sure
you guys might notice that I'm now doing
a KU bukan I know we changed it up today
we changed it up man and my other drink
that I like is mojito
yeah so I made some [ __ ] good million
my mojito is kind of like I don't know
you can look up the you could look it up
it's kind of like it's kind of like a
caipirinha but instead of Kasasa
you use rum and then you add fresh mint
to it yeah fresh mint li yeah and then
on top of that then you add a club soda
to it to give it kind of like a
sparkling you know effect this good is
kind of you know it's refreshing yeah
it's all Caribbean and shit's Florida
stuff actually I think it's from from
Puerto Rico I think yeah I think the
guys were wrong but but yeah they're
especially good with fresh mint in it
because this is the first time the last
batch we made we I got some of that at
time stuff
yeah Brack
it's good but it's not quite the same
you're not good so you go to Publix cuz
we live in Florida and public she's like
the best grocery store and they have
like these little packets of like
organic fresh yeah
in the grocer's and you just put them in
there man crush that [ __ ] up down on the
bottom with and then you make your own
simple syrup and then you put lime juice
and then you pour that rum in there ice
mix it and then top it off with the damn
club soda and mix it it's like the best
most refreshing alcoholic soda you would
ever have oh yeah and you know there's
guys in Britain in England trying to
remake Google car guava and everything
if you if you've never had a [ __ ]
mojito make a mojito and real mojitos in
a glass jar drink that [ __ ] out of it
especially good in the summer I think
cuz they're like very very I mean you
know if you're in the northern
hemisphere it's always out here though
that's that's what I mean Florida it's
like so it's just like summer all year
round very much which is kind of a
bummer but yeah they're better when it's
a hot outside yeah well yeah so let's
just do a couple of very brief shout
outs like we do is very beginning again
my book faceless villain 3 is out in all
formats if you have not read it yet or
if you have read it but you'd like to
leave a review that would be a big help
associated villanies like I said the
print and ebook is up by the time this
show goes up the audiobook may be out
like I said it usually takes two weeks
from when you upload it and I think it's
been about that long so it should be
about time also as usual our Halloween
show which is on gonna be on what the
29th or something like that
we are gonna probably read you know
peeps Tories that people have sent in
like scary stories either true or
fictional it'll be a long show as long
as they're not too long yeah I also and
somebody else's somebody in the YouTube
comments had a really good idea to they
said you know uh um you know in addition
to like reading people's stories and
stuff we could also go into like history
of Halloween different Halloween
costumes and stuff like that and I was
like yeah that's pretty cool because
we've never like actually done that
before
yeah which is kind of hard to believe so
I said yes and then that way if we don't
get like a [ __ ] ton of stories then
we'll have other shows talked about yeah
not like you ever run over stuff I
talked about I could talk about anything
all day long
I'll just make it up as I go yep well
you have to well you know how like
magicians like pulled all of this like
handkerchiefs out of a hat he does that
picks up pulling facts out of his ass
yeah that's not true though exactly i
have i have an egg cyclopædia
encyclopedic knowledge and then i
cross-reference and just combine
knowledge together you know I mean
anybody can do it you just you know it's
gonna be creative gotta be creative you
know and confident you won't say things
with conviction well now a lot of the
[ __ ] I know or or or I feel it or I can
feel that it might be likely you know
man but what I do I ask a lot of
questions you not I mean that's yeah I'm
probably asking you more questions that
I'm saying things it just sounds like
I'm making statements but questioning
you yeah you know and you're like one of
those don't question me [ __ ]
kind of persons you know man I see how
you do it so cuz if she gets mad she's
got to go to the notes but you know I
mean if I sometimes you're skipping like
way ahead yeah well good thing is that
you know if I have a question that I
know their audience Frye has a question
yeah you know but you have to be also
you have to be patient because I usually
get to the [ __ ] we could always pause
that [ __ ] though and there's an edited
out and then [ __ ] like I said it you
know unless things go wildly off the
rails which they don't usually or unless
like I lose my place my notes these are
made like I take very little out
seriously he's just dream a calm I mean
I think the last show that we did which
was almost three hours long we did it in
like chunks and then we took like a
10-minute break and then we did another
chunk and so yeah but I think the only
thing I took out literally a minute
because I was reading I was like going
through my notes and I totally lost my
place and then I was like a lost my
place then I went like that so that was
all I took out yeah out of that whole
three hours sometimes you know I'll say
some [ __ ] and I'll be like I can't be
right then I go back and check and I was
right
kind of like the mountain lion the
Cougar and the Puma yeah as being all
the same thing yeah yeah I mean I felt
that they were all this I suspected as
much but I wasn't sure I don't like sure
entirely I went back and checked that's
the same [ __ ] animal so we just all
have different names for it yeah I think
there might be regional breeds that
might be slightly different
yeah probably I mean like everything's a
dog but you know Germans between a damn
German Shepherd in it but you know the
difference between them or not - yeah
right but I think they're all they're
all the same we're getting back on
another subject but yeah so if you want
to submit some horror stories either
fictional or true like I said as long as
they're not way too long then I'll put
an email address in the description that
you can send them to I've already got
two or three so that'll be good and like
I said we'll talk about some other [ __ ]
to fill out the show it'll be another
fun long show like we usually do know
what else I thought was also like a
mountain lion and pool and ochita what's
that a Lincoln it's like a Lincoln
continent like a lake I know your damn
car commercials and I was a little kid
they'd had that Lincoln Mercury Cougar
commercial they had a damn cougar on top
and I knew a mercury wasn't it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't a cougar
but a Lincoln might be a cougar though
also maybe that's a good time across the
kind of cross wired in my head sometimes
some people would say Lincoln I would
think of a [ __ ] cougar Malcolm a
mountain lion well that's completely
understood well cuz if you're a kid and
you don't know yeah the card is yours
like maybe that's the Cougars name is
Lee yeah that's Lincoln the Cougar
somehow I got cross-wired in there
[Laughter]
Oh commercials like messed us up links a
Manx and a minx I thought was all the
same thing too didn't doesn't mix was a
[ __ ] yeah it's more like a cute girl I
guess right or like I didn't I never
watches it's like a talk let that hoe
over there hmm
I always thought of it more like um
someone that was like flirtatious okay
which I guess she could kind of read as
a [ __ ] nice and nothing wrong and lots
of men [ __ ] are awesome
but I just think that's do everything
yeah there's all kinds I had all kinds
of [ __ ] crossword yeah I bet you did
alright so let's start talking about
some poisoners are doing five different
ones never on this and this first one
that we're gonna talk about this
this [ __ ] dude right here this was
actually a recommendation by a listener
I can't remember who it was it was in
youtube so a while back we are talking
about the infamous Graham Young also
known as the teacup poisoner or the st.
Albans poisoner in 1995 they actually
made a movie about him called the young
poisoners handbook which is it says it's
loosely based on its life but it's
pretty similar because I've seen it they
actually made a black comedy out of it
which I thought was cool but also sort
of weird cuz he did actually tell people
you know what I mean it's like yeah it
was kind of funny I get it but yeah so
he was a British and he was one this is
a guy you know how we talk a lot about
on these serial killer shows about you
know nature versus nurture and all this
other kind of stuff this dude I think he
was one of those ones it was maybe
messed up from the beginning like I
think there was something to matter with
this kid
well what happened yeah alright so
Graham young was born in a town called
knees Dhin in Middlesex now his mom died
only a few months after he was born and
his dad thinking well I'm a man so I'm
not just gonna take care of kids by
myself it's you know the 1940s so he
sent Graham the baby off to within it
with an aunt and uncle and he had also
had an older sister and he sent the
older sister off to stay with the
grandparents now from the time that
Graham was very very young I mean at
some point his dad remarried and you
know brought the kids back and
everything like that but from the time
the kid was very young he was super
super fascinated by poisons also
fascinated by Nazis so you know what I
mean that's kind of a couple it's a
little red flag right there um he was
just like he always wanted chemistry
says he was pretty much useless at every
other school topic except for chemistry
which he was super super good at but he
was like really really into it
now he actually when he was 14 years old
in 1961 he started to test out poisons
on his family members today mostly
antimony which is like a heavy man
timoni
yes we called here yeah we'd say
pronounce it like that in antimony used
it in casting bullets yeah yeah among
other things all right now he reportedly
did not like his stepmother Molly very
much so he decided to start giving her
poison now she was 37 years old at the
time so she started having obviously a
lot of unexplained illnesses
you know diarrhea vomiting a really bad
stomach pain now for a long time
obviously wouldn't didn't suspect
anything because why would you she
thought it was what they used to call
bilious attacks attacks which is like
anything by all related or they think
it's something wrong with your liver
that makes you puke and gives you nausea
and stuff like that's the old-timey word
for it room so um Graham's dad Fred who
was 44 at the time he also started to
get like really bad stomach cramps and
like not just like oh my tummy hurts but
it's like so bad that he was like you
know they were doubled over in pain he
couldn't go to work and [ __ ] like that
he's trying to knock him off yeah 14 he
is 14 yeah this is [ __ ] special this
is what it like [ __ ] made a movie
about this dude uh he also gave the
poison to his sister who's gonna shoot
the air of him if all these people die I
don't think he was thinking about that
honestly um yeah so she was also getting
violently ill um and then some of his
little friends at school also started
getting very sick know what is putting
this together though because why would
you everyone was thought it was like a
virus like a bad virus that was going
around now in November of 1961 Winifred
who was grams gram Young's older sister
um Graham brought her a cup of tea that
he had made because no one suspected
anything at the time
she took a sip of it but it tasted so
bad that she threw it out so she like
swallowed one mouthful and she's like oh
that was yucky and then she threw it out
and then she went to work so she's on
the train an hour after she gets on the
train like on the way to work she
started to hallucinate damn
so obviously doctors came they got her
off the train they took her to the
hospital and they found out that she had
been exposed to Atropa belladonna
otherwise known as deadly nightshade
yeah it makes you hallucinate well it
made her to loosen a for-sure now at
this point this seems a little weird and
Graham Young's dad finally he knew that
the kid was into chemistry and was
really you know fascinated by that so at
this point he starts to suspect this
fourteen-year-old kid so he says what
the [ __ ] did you poison your sister or
whatever and he goes no I didn't do
anything he's like Winifred who was the
sister she must have been using the tea
cups to like mix shampoo or like mix
cosmetics or something like that that
was his story now the dad Fred did not
buy this obviously from fantastical tale
however he goes and like you know turns
over Graham's room and like searches
everything but he doesn't find anything
incriminating um so all he could
basically do was just be like well you
know just be careful with those chemical
that with that chemistry set and you
know quit [ __ ] around and everything
like that now another thing that I
should note is that later on yeah you
know when after he'd been caught and
everything like that they said something
very curious about Graham was that and
this is what I said why I think maybe he
was probably born this way was that he
was super detached he was just very
methodically giving them different types
of poisons and different doses and
seeing what would happen and he had this
big-ass notebook and he wrote every
single thing in it I gave them this many
milligrams of this and then at this time
this happened like they started vomiting
it this happened and he had like [ __ ]
books of the [ __ ]
you must have some kind of dam on the
spectrum or something they asked us
burgers um people later later on like
they didn't call it that then but later
on other people that have like looked at
his you know at his profile and stuff
like that have have thought that
probably he was on the autism spectrum
but he what you know kid doesn't care
enough to keep records and normal you
know 14-year old it's not doing that
kind of stuff yeah
even if he's committing crimes he's
usually not keeping records of it yeah
fourteen-year-old boy it's part of the
moment they said he was like super super
focused yeah that sounds like on what
burgers well and like I said he was
almost kind of like it it just reminded
me of like those horrible like old like
Nazi experiments and stuff like that
religion what's so twins together and
see what happened you know what I mean
it's like he was very much like that he
was just this very detached kid and he
was just like watching them like they
were bugs like under a microscope or
something it was just like super creepy
now on the Saturday before Easter of
1962 which was the 21st of April
Graham's stepmother Molly died from the
poisoning hmm
now after that his father who was also
sick because he had been getting the
same poison and around the same rate he
got really sick and was taken to the
hospital and the doctors finally like
realized what the what the poisoning was
and said okay well it's good you came
here because one more dose would have
killed you
kids psycho yeah so at this point when
the dad I mean the stepmom is dead the
dad is in the hospital you know near
death he did eventually recover at this
point Graham Young's aunt who he had
lived with a little while when he was a
baby
um said you know I think that he is
poisoning his family and also his
science teacher was suspicious of him
also because like I said he had this is
super weird like fixation with poisons
and stuff now apparently his science
teacher whose name was mr. Hughes also
found a bunch of bottles of poison in
his desk at school
hmm so they actually went to the
headmaster of the school that he was
going to and said hey we think this kid
may be poisoning his fan
so they set Graham to a psychiatrist and
the psychiatrist said call the cops
yes it's kids crazy yeah so Graham young
was actually arrested on May 23rd 1962
there's no word on what the psychiatrist
said about him I don't know yeah he just
he just said I think that you know that
he's doing it and that he's dangerous so
call the cops and we need to do
something about this so they arrested
him like I said he was only 14 years old
at the time and he actually did confess
to murdering his stepmother and attempt
you know attempted murder on his father
sister and a friend of his at school
because that what had happened with the
stepmother molly was that when she died
they didn't realize that it was
poisoning they thought that she had died
from complications because she had had
like a car accident like a year before
and it had like a lingering injury so
they thought that maybe that's what had
caused it so they didn't really look
into it and they also ended up cremating
her because Graham the kid told them
that that's what they should do they
should cream it so they cremated her so
they couldn't chance so you know so weak
they couldn't get him for murder because
all of his other poisoning victims have
lived so much more I'm surprised at this
point that this young man doesn't have
any sexual problems I know I had sexual
problem quite a trauma yeah yeah we know
all about your sex life make a little
t-shirt that says sexual problem yeah so
they send Graham young to Broadmoor the
very famous mental hospital and he that
he was assessed by two or three
different psychiatrists before they sent
him there they diagnosed him with
personality disorder and schizophrenia
and as I said later researchers that
have looked into his case in his profile
suspect that he may have also been on
the autism spectrum now because what he
had done was so egregious I guess she
could say that
they said well any anything that you
want to do any kind of leave that you
give him any type like if you're
thinking about releasing him or anything
like that you have to clear it with the
Home Secretary first now the the
recommendation was that he not be let
out for 15 years that you know they
didn't think he should however he only
stayed it ended up staying in there 9
years and while he was in there even
though they didn't figure this out until
later on he actually was able to get his
hands on some poisons one thing that he
would do and this is how good at [ __ ]
chemistry and [ __ ] he was there were
these laurel bushes on the grounds of
Broadmoor Hospital and he was able to
get the plants from that and get cyanide
out of it hmm and he used that on one
other I believe it was another inmate
who died and they didn't find that out
until later on he had also poisoned some
of the staff members but they didn't die
so he must have figured he must have
known chemistry he wasn't just copying
yes yes process oh yeah okay that's what
I said they said that he was like super
super good at it right because that was
like all he was interested in that in
Nazis that's about it so I wonder what
the connection between poisons and Nazis
are that the poisons used used gas maybe
that's what it was and maybe like I said
it was kind of like a power like a
dehumanizing thing like he just got off
on experimenting on people yeah you know
what I mean
so it might have been that like that was
will you resist
late for more we're talking about the
60s right now a teenager early 60s okay
but yeah so now apparently for the first
couple years when he was in Broadmoor he
didn't really make much of a secret
about like his fascination with poisons
like his trying to get his hands on him
and [ __ ] like that but then he
eventually figured out that if he wanted
to be let out at any point that he would
have to like pretend that he was cured
and he was apparently I mean according
to everybody and I
a couple documentaries about him as well
it's like people that had that had
spoken with him and were like his
doctors and stuff and they said that he
was a very very intelligent and
manipulative kid so that once he figured
out Oh to get let out I'm gonna have to
pretend that I don't that I'm interested
in this [ __ ] anymore so that's exactly
what he did and it worked nine years
later they said oh well he's he's done
with all that you know he's completely
cured and they let him out now how many
people did he kill already at this point
uh he killed his stepmom and then in
Broadmoor he killed another jealous dad
all right
no he almost did that he did attempted
murder on his dad his sister and a
school friend of his and then like I
said he killed a guy in Broadmoor as
well like another patient and no real
motive I mean he wasn't mad about
anything no need to have like a normal
family life that's what I mean he was
just like a really he just seemed very
detached
like he didn't see other people as
people and he just wanted to see what
would happen that's all that seems to be
the only motive that he had he just
wanted to see what would happen he was
just curious I guess that's what's so
weird about him he just he said he just
seems like completely sociopath kind of
weird thing going on in his head he's
fantasizing about you know them dying I
think he's just saying that he's just
cured I mean you know what's gonna
happen yeah I mean if you poison
somebody kills him you know yeah but I
mean well he didn't kill everybody he
poisoned in fact most people that he
poisoned he did [ __ ] I think he just got
him sick and he was just interested to
see what the symptoms were and like what
different dosages would do it seemed
like because like I said he'd kept a
record like a very detailed record of
everything like how much he'd given it
what it what it did at certain dosages
and stuff so it seemed like you know
what I mean he wanted to know everything
about poison
yeah for whatever reason it's okay some
people collect baseball cards you know
it's just like he just got like indle in
the interests lottery he just got the
most [ __ ] up what's weird I'm trying
to I'm trying to attribute this to some
deeper darker motive but there doesn't
really seem to be one there he just
might be you know like I said mental
yeah that's what I'm saying that's why I
kind of find this guy fascinating
because he seems almost like a hollow
shell of a person yeah like he just
seems like he wants to like he doesn't
he like you said he doesn't seem like he
had any rage he didn't have like any
abuse issues I mean his mom died when he
was a baby and stuff like that but I
don't think he was abused or mistreated
or anything like that it just seems that
he just perceived other people as like
guinea pigs to experiment on and he was
just interested to see what would happen
some people said that you know
Psychopaths certain types of Psychopaths
just seem like lizards yeah just robotic
so that you know everything's got an
artificial so he might be just one of
those that's what I'm thinking it's just
more of like a robot yeah I mean clearly
he didn't give a [ __ ] about anyone or
anything other than poisoning people so
he gets released from Broadmoor in
February of 1971 now he gets a job as a
quartermaster at a place called john
haplin laboratories which was in
Bovington Bovington Hertfordshire now he
specifically wanted to work at this
place obvious like I said he's got a
[ __ ] one-track mind because this
company manufactured thallium bromide
iodide infrared lenses which were like
military equipment so he was all excited
to get a job there because he thought oh
he could get he could steal thallium
from work he could start poisoning
business just really bad yeah
that's also a heavy metal yeah um and
take much of it yeah so he was very he
said we got the job there but then he
was very disappointed to find that they
didn't store anything him on site and
that he would have to go to some other
chemist and London to get it because now
he was like curious to use this one and
see what would happen with that yes kids
a robot now interestingly as I said um
what an up happening because they
thought he had been in Broadmoor for
nine years they thought he was cured you
know he was only 14 when he went in so
when he came out there wasn't a huge
amount of follow-up and I guess because
he'd been a miner it didn't say anything
about his records being sealed because
they do that a lot at least in the
United States like if you commit crimes
as a miner usually
you know after they let you out if they
let you out like when you're over the
age of majority a lot of times the
records will be sealed so if you do like
a criminal background check it won't
come up because they figured you know if
you you did some [ __ ] when you were a
kid and you're done with it I try to
give you a second shake they're trying
to give you a C yet so you don't like
[ __ ] up your whole entire life for
something you do when you're a teenager
so it so happened that when he got the
job at this place they didn't know that
he had a history as a poisoner so no red
flags were raised as I said there was
also not a lot of follow up like he
didn't he had a probation officer but
they never like seemed to turn up like
they weren't really around they never
showed up at his work to like see it was
a threat yeah it's well like I said it
seems like he fooled the psychiatrist's
into thinking that he had gotten over it
and since he was just a kid they figured
oh well he's okay now and now he's gonna
be like a productive member of society I
mean you know there's no way of knowing
the date where did they know that he
murdered that other guy at the at the
hospital not until later I don't think
okay and they weren't quite sure if he
poisoned his mom or his stepmom
he confessed to it when they caught him
yeah and he confessed to poisoning his
the other three people too but you know
he didn't kill so he was responsible for
one death they knew that yeah and
Stiller just kind of blowing it off yeah
all right well and like I said the guy
that died in the hospital I don't think
they were aware that that was him until
later you know what I mean so he gets
this job at this at this place not too
long after he started working there you
will not be shocked to hear that his
Foreman whose name was Bob Eagle got
sick and died yeah it turned out that
Gramm young was making tea for all of
his fellow employees and was putting
poison in it yeah because he it seems
like he could just couldn't help himself
they'd do it you know what you know
who's coming to mind when you're telling
me the stories of this kid what that
Adam Lanza had a connection now yeah
Adam Lanza he was the one tick his mom's
a are just gunned down all those little
kids at the school yeah I saw a video
him dancing doing like
dancing on one of those video games and
saw pictures of him and just heard what
he would you know heard him kind of
described and I bet you if you were to
put this guy and Adam Lanza in the same
room and just took their names away you
didn't know what they look like you'd
have a hard time telling the two apart
in terms of which one was the mass
shooter and which one was the mass
poisoner yeah you know I mean I'm just I
bet you they were very similar that's
what I'm getting at
yeah I bet you they were very similar
type people no it's a robot yeah well
like I said Rokan robots it seems like a
very it's very um I mean you have to see
people as less than human right to do
that kind of yeah and here's the thing
you know some people won't matter tom
how can you say that this is a boy this
is a human being and they go off on all
that [ __ ] now I'm unfazed because you
know we live in in frontal lobes
basically you you have to have a brain
your brain has to be functioning
property to be fully sentient and to be
fully sentient as a human that's what
makes you a human some people don't have
those functions there are more like
robots and broken robots there they have
human DNA but they don't have a human
perception of the world and I have human
feelings
yeah just sorry yeah don't mean what say
all right clearly does not yeah I mean
as long as you people been listening to
this show if you haven't figured out
that there are some people that are just
straight-up [ __ ] subhuman then go
ahead and check out cuz some Ammar
they're [ __ ] all the horrible [ __ ] we
talked about on this show even couldn't
because we talked about like say yeah
human couldn't really do a lot of that
stuff yeah I mean broken robot percent
yeah and like I said this kid well he's
not a kid anymore because you know now
he's in his early 20s and I'm in let out
but and I'm a X Infantry [ __ ]
that would [ __ ] you up but I'm still
human being you had to deserve it you
see if we're doing it to [ __ ] the people
that don't even deserve it
and they even mad at him yeah and this
guy like I said it's one it seemed like
he couldn't help himself he didn't seem
terribly concerned about getting caught
he starts working at this place and then
just starts putting poison to the tea
just cause yeah just cuz he wanted to
see what would happen
they need to be in a needed to be in an
institution for life yeah they didn't
put him in for as long I mean they they
wanted him to stay in for 15 years at
least but he didn't he got it after nine
years yeah there are some people just
like I said this kid she like defective
yeah like from the beginning they didn't
send that one back to the manufacturer
you know what I'm saying like I think
it's very rare that somebody is born
that's just gonna be evil no matter what
like I think that like I said in most
cases I think that has to be nature and
nurture combined this kid though he
seemed like he just wasn't right there
are some people that are born mindless -
yeah I mean they just never like they
never wake up or they're just they're
screaming infants for the rest of their
lives you know yeah just like I said
this guy just seemed like different
versions of that this one is just like I
said he's a broken robot yeah yeah so
yeah so he starts putting poison in the
tea at this [ __ ] place that he works
he killed his Foreman Bob Eagle as I
said a mysterious illness starts
sweeping through the through the work
place where he worked which they which
everyone at first attributed to a virus
which they called the Bovington bug some
of the people got sick enough that they
had to be hospitalized during this time
period it is thought that grim young
poisoned seven people that they didn't
die except for his Foreman he did die
now they brought in another Foreman and
he got sick too as soon as he started
working there because he was being
poisoned but he quit so he actually did
end up living now a few months after
that another guy that worked there named
Fred Biggs now he also got sick and they
sent him to what was then called the
London National Hospital for nervous
diseases
but it was actually too late once he got
to the hospital and he just got sicker
and sicker and sicker and eventually
ended up dying so that's for now that's
for people he's killed and a whole bunch
of the couple dozen other than he's
[ __ ] poisoned now at this stage
they're getting a little suspicious of
this kid
him pretend he didn't really help his
case when the investigators come in
because they start to suspect poison or
that there was something like you know
on the work grounds that was causing
everyone to get sick because it seemed
like at this point they they don't think
it's a virus anymore
Graham young straight up asks the
investigators have you considered valium
poisoning mm-hmm they're like no we
hadn't considered that but is that what
it is you bring it up yeah that's
probably what it is
he had also told somebody that he worked
with that he was super into like
studying toxic chemicals so you know
everyone's like all the fingers were
pointing right at this [ __ ] kid so
the colleague that he had told this to
went to the cops that the cops went back
through his record for minors they found
out about his criminal record like from
being a minor poisoning people so they
said okay well this is obviously the
dude so they arrested him again in
November of 1971 at his arrest
they found phalion in his pocket turned
around in his pocket well this is what
he called a vine reportedly yeah
reportedly this is what he called his
exit dose which he had planned to take
in case he ever got caught right but I
guess they caught him and they got it
out of his pocket before again good too
they also found a bunch of other poisons
in his home including more thallium
aconitine various other things and they
found his Diaries yeah which basically
had all the doses he had given to people
like what they had done whether he was
going to let that person live or die so
I guess that he was like deciding it's
like well I'm just gonna make this one
like super super sick and miserable for
a little while but I'm not gonna kill
them gee kids he's getting something out
of it price some kind of godlike power
that's what I mean it seems like this
big kind of power trip thing so he goes
to trial in June of 1972 the trial
lasted for ten days he pleaded not
guilty okay
saying that the diary was actually not
real that he was actually writing a
novel and that so that he had just made
it all up
part of his novel unclear fiction nice
try yeah the jury did not buy it he was
convicted and sentenced to life in
prison and dubbed the teacup poisoner by
the press since he had poisoned all this
while he was in prison he befriended
another shining example of humanity
[ __ ] Ian Brady one of the Moors
murderers which one was that he was it
was so him and Myra Hindley's little
kids because Ian Brady was all in it no
it's also ended Nazis so they bonded
over their shared love you Nazis that's
just that's so charming yes [ __ ] hell
so yeah these two losers like hang out
in prison all the time and grab young
actually ended up dying in his cell at
Parker's prison in August of 1990 one
month before his 43rd birthday it must
have made its cause of death was
myocardial infarction otherwise there
was a heart attack
apparently he just dropped dead well
they did a post-mortem because they
couldn't find it well they didn't find
any poison although wouldn't that have
been yeah poetic justice to make poison
well he can make poison and you'd think
that he would have taken it himself
because like I said he what he made a
big deal I had a lot of friends in
budget he pride a lot of friends in
prison had a good time he probably did
yeah cuz I I don't know man that's just
like a lot of those dudes are like that
you know I mean they they have more more
of a life inside prison than out yeah
cuz they can be honest about who they
are and brag about what they did and
then everybody's gonna be like him oh
yeah yeah the poison man yeah okay you
sit next to me we'll watch TV [ __ ] like
that you know think about well he was
basically you know how long was he in
the mental institution nine years yeah
well so he kind of grew up in that
environment and prison was probably
better than the mental institution yeah
imagine mental institutions put a
terrible I've heard Broadmoor was pretty
bad yeah I mean it was the largest one
it's them it's the most famous one who's
not gonna had a girlfriend care yeah
they never really mentioned anything
about that he did really
like I said all he was interested in was
poison and not days yeah so very narrow
kind of yeah whatever now as I said in
1995 they made a very good movie
actually should go check it out if you
can called the young poisoners handbook
which is loosely based on his life
although they've turned it into a black
comedy um there is also a case in and
this is kind of terrible but November
2005 a sixteen-year-old japanese
schoolgirl was arrested for poisoning
her mother with Salim because she
claimed to be fascinated with Graham
young after seeing the young poisoners
handbook and she kept an online blog
detailing all the [ __ ] of all the people
that she poisoned because she just found
so there's another one yeah there's your
girlfriend winner winners everywhere
winners everywhere yeah so yeah that was
the case of Graham young the very famous
teacup poisoner and a [ __ ] up human
being who killed four people and
poisoned many many more and made them
very sick and miserable so there you go
the asshat poison indeed all right now
the next case I want to talk about is
one that I admit that I had not heard of
that this was also another
recommendation not a huge amount of
information about it because they never
caught this person or persons this is
known as the paraquat murders and this
happened in Japan in the mid-1980s
now what is crazy about this one it's
very similar to you guys remember the
Chicago tylenol poisonings I actually
put it it's in faceless villain 3 we're
like I haven't been seven people died or
something like that where somebody was
like stealing or buying packages of
Tylenol and like putting cyanide in
there and then putting him back on the
shelf
yeah like for people to buy and it
finally caught the guy no they never did
they didn't catch that guy that got him
confused no they didn't catch that guy
um and this was another person I'm
assuming it's a guy but they never
caught this guy either the weird thing
about this one this so this is what ends
up happening the first victim of this as
I said this took place in Japan the
first victim was Haru Otsu and he was
going fishing one morning
in April of 1985 he stops at one of the
ubiquitous vending machines in Japan
because you know you can buy everything
in a vending machine in Japan and I
guess you could even a nice life I buy
dirty panties in it damn
I've heard that also that you could buy
like used underwear I don't know if
that's still the case but you can buy
you could buy like alcoholic beverages
you can buy like a pornographic
magazines I'm like man that sounds like
pretty awesome you can just like [ __ ]
buy anybody
everything in a vending machine but this
guy he was going fishing and he bought
like a fairly normal thing from a
vending machine not dirty panties he
actually bought two bottles of this
drink it's like a vitamin juice I guess
it's kind of like vitamin water or
something like that vitamin juice or you
know some kind of drink that has like
vitamins in it okay and it's called aura
Naaman sea all right and they said it
was in the 80s I don't know about now
but they said in the 80s it was like a
really popular drink for like
middle-aged men because it's supposed to
be like good for you because it's that
like vitamins and stuff in it right so
he gets two bottles of the stuff he was
52 years old he drinks one bottle and
it's fine but then he gets halfway
through the second bottle and starts to
feel really ill so a couple hours after
that you know the illness has progressed
to a point where he gets taken to a
hospital near his house the following
night he died did he now what this
person or persons was doing the poisoner
that was up to that was doing this what
they were doing was they were putting
paraquat which is an actually an
herbicide they usually use it over here
for killing marijuana plants like the
Drug Enforcement Agency when they find
like a marijuana stash like out in the
woods or something they used that to
kill marijuana plants but it's a pretty
common particularly in Japan and
particularly the 1980s you know since
there were a lot of farms and stuff in
this part of Japan it was pretty easy to
get like you didn't have to have like
any special anything you could just
pretty much buy it over the counter if
you gave them your name and address it's
kind of like lying around up there yeah
it's it was a similar type of thing and
I should note too that particularly the
80s I don't know about now but paraquat
was a pretty common thing to use too
it's suicide with yeah like by drinking
it I would assume yeah give her her
aunty she likes that but whoever this
person or persons was that did these
paraquat burners what they were doing
was that they would buy a drink from a
vending machine they would put paraquat
in it and then they would put the bottle
back into the little slot at the bottom
so that when somebody put coins into the
vending machine and like got their
bottle out and then they would open and
there be two in there and they'd be like
whoo I got a free one yeah except one of
them was poisoned so special this little
stunt that these people pulled ended up
killing 10 or 11 people damn and made 35
others seriously ill between the one two
stunts they were trying to kill people
that mean they they knew that it was
killing people yeah they kept doing yeah
the one guy probably serial killer
that's what it seems sir a poisoner
probably some dude well you know I hated
the world [ __ ] you you know I kind of
he's one of those guys yeah so between
September and November of 1985 35 people
injured 11 people that was it always the
same brand of soda I don't think so I
think it was just pretty much any drink
that they could get there was not a
disgruntled employee anything like that
I mean as far as I know they just ed it
was like sodas or so I remember the
tylenol one people thought that maybe it
was an ex tylenol employee trying to
bring it yeah because they did use like
extra strength tylenol that was all of
them yeah I think the guy just bought a
case of tylenol and poisoned it yeah
well he was going back in the stores and
putting them on the put back on the
shelf but I think he bought a case yeah
so he had a lot of shots yeah and then
he redid him and then did it all because
later on like after people started dying
and they made the connection then they
like went to the particulars it was only
in the Chicago area pretty much Chicago
and like the outlying suburbs and they
went to a couple of stores and they
found some of the packages that were
still poisoning the chili people I
thought were all the tylenols did all of
them have cyanide no um I think it was
just because what you would do cuz back
then you could just pull the capsule
apart yeah and you could put cyanide in
there bro and then put it back I don't
know if he did all of them are just like
some of them
but that's the whole reason and for all
the you youngsters out there that don't
know that's the reason that they do
caplets now and they don't do those pull
apart capsules that's exactly why
because of that Chicago tylenol
poisoning case that happened back then
also that's why we have those like that
induction seal that they put on there
and like the job seals and everything
yeah they made well you gotta say like
props to Johnson & Johnson who makes
tylenol as soon as they found out what
was going on they pulled all that [ __ ]
right off the shelves they you know got
with the government and like said what
can we do to prevent this happening and
like they changed all their packaging
and changed everything so you know but
yeah so whoever was doing this was just
like I said putting the [ __ ] in the
drinks and then putting the drinks back
in the like the the thing of the vending
machine now the creepy thing about it
they never did catch the person that did
it and then there were also like a bunch
of copycat crimes where there was one
place in central Japan where someone was
like leaving with like poisoning the
milk containers like for school kids and
[ __ ] like that there was also in 1984
there was kind of a big famous case
about a person or people that again they
never caught that called themselves the
mystery man with 21 faces and they would
try to extort food companies by saying
hey we're gonna put poison in your
product if you don't give us X amount of
money now no one died in that case
because one of the weird things that
they would do was that they would put
cyanide on a bunch of candy put the
candy back on the shelves but then they
would put a sticker on it saying this is
this Candy's poisoned pretty much so I
don't think they wanted to kill anybody
I think they just want to just want to
extort money yeah so those people never
got caught either but nobody got killed
now what you you mentioned this vet that
one Japanese killer was [ __ ]
poisoning the children's milk children
milk well there's a cosmic serpent CA
and LA why I think it's lau i 86 there
youtubers innate they lived in China
they married Chinese girls alright
they're out of there now I think because
damn you know all the things going on in
Hong Kong but they were living in
mainland China and in mainland China all
they hear about in terms of the United
States is all these school shootings
yeah but what's happening in China they
have the same thing they have school
stabbings and what will happen is just
like some disgruntled dude or right who
just is pissed off at life will get one
of them traditional Chinese meat
cleavers or a [ __ ] butcher knife or
kitchen knife and break into a school
and they'll stab like stab and kill like
4050 kids I hadn't heard about that
happen and it's not rare I mean I mean
well it's rare but it's they do it even
more than say school shootings here here
we got school shootings over there they
got school stabbings and it's not
students it's grown men yeah like in
their forties or fifties going in there
and beheading and chopping up a little
like three and four-year-olds and you
know they did a whole show on it and the
Chinese government keeps it quiet but
that happens all time and they think it
has something to do with because in
Chinese culture kids are like especially
the young boys are so valuable and so
precious well like I said that way
everywhere in every culture but they're
just striking at the heart of the
Chinese mind you know yeah but it's
funny that in the Eastern countries
there's a lot of mass crime towards
children that's like when it when it
dude go psycho that's what he wants to
do at least in China because it'll cause
them it'll cause the most damage yeah
and you would think that you know that
they have a all those countries kind of
have you know the reputation of being
kind of safe they have their own version
is safe I think that's a good way to put
it you don't learn about they have a
different set of crimes that they deal
with that's a trip that's all I want to
say just take it off on a tangent and
how it is see if you guys want a lot
about Shadow Man go check out serpent za
or Lao I yeah they have a lot of good
videos so the thing about this though
and like ice
I was just talking about the Chicago
tylenol murders where as soon as that
happened you know Johnson & Johnson and
the government kind of like got together
and were like you know we need to
prevent this and they passed like all
kind of new laws they made it a federal
offence to tamper with consumer products
which it hadn't been previously and [ __ ]
like that but in light of these
poisonings in Japan in these vending
machines it seemed like the soda
companies didn't really want to do
anything about it because they were like
well our sales haven't been affected it
would cost us millions of dollars today
all that tamper-proof [ __ ] we don't
want to do that and they also at least
at least one soda company executive kind
of blamed the victim because he said hey
if you open the soda bottle and you you
know you would be able to tell if it had
been adulterated because it did have a
seal on it and like if it had been
broken off that somebody put [ __ ]
poison in there then that's kind of on
you so it's like people should be more
careful so basically all they did was
like printed out a whole bunch of
stickers that like put it on vending
machines and said hey is that if there's
a free one and the thing like don't take
it because it's probably poisoned but
that's kind of all they did about it but
they never did catch the person or
people that did this type of [ __ ] some
loser yeah and like I said as far as I
know it was just that one year it was
like in 1985 that that happened and like
I said 11 people died 35 people injured
from the poisonings but they never
caught the person that was never any
motive there was never anything like
that according to according to do you
know what lau i am [ __ ] certain za
said eastern crimes are different they
tend to be societal type of crimes where
a guy feels that society has [ __ ] him
over so he's gonna strike back you know
I mean at society at large which just
means random crime yeah kind of like you
know you're all guilty about [ __ ] I
didn't do a job I wanted that guys yeah
yeah yeah so you have those kind of
crimes here it's just in the east there
are more of them and less of the kind of
stuff that you would have over here yeah
I have you know um it's dim proportions
yeah they did it show on it was pretty
interesting yeah like you know liquor
store
it's common here doesn't even I barely
meet and they don't have hardly get on
the news in certain Eastern countries
that's just unheard of well not our
liquor stores convenience stores in
general yeah yes I meant convenience
stores like I mean I've everybody I know
that's worked in a convenience store cuz
my dad you still like managed several of
them and stuff like that and everyone I
know that's worked in one or managed one
has been held up at least once my dad's
been held up three times yeah so that I
know of he worked at a magic market and
it worked at 7-eleven yeah but yeah so
so like I said they they did kind of
look into maybe we should change the
vending machine so like it won't let you
put money in if there's already
something in the little you know the
little flappy thing was it drop yeah you
know time I cuz you see the product yeah
it's far away it falls yeah down to the
bottoms on the corkscrew or it's in a
[ __ ] it's it's in his own little room
room and it rotates over it's all glass
you see it then it comes down give you a
slice of pie something like that I don't
know for some reason I just like this is
why I'm always and I think a lot of
Americans probably have this because we
have vending machines obviously but um
it seems like Japan has such a like a
wide panoply of them and they have like
a lot more stuff in them then we have
plus like I said you can just be like
walking down the street and get a
[ __ ] beer out of a [ __ ] vending
machine man like them you can't do that
here Japan likes the automated service
they like doing people will see I would
like that I don't like dealing with
people either if I could get everything
out of a vending machine I totally would
I mean the Internet's the best invention
ever cuz it's like I need some shampoo
and it's like I can just [ __ ] order
from Amazon edge of the only place
eventually all these uh fast-food
restaurants like McDonald's and Burger
King and [ __ ] it'll just be a vending
machine eventually you remember back in
the old day twelve this is like before
our time obviously but those [ __ ]
what do they call those restaurants
where what was it it wasn't even a
restaurant not really but it was just
kind of like where you went in it was
like a cafeteria type situation and then
everything was like this little like
slices of pie and sandwiches and [ __ ]
like that and they were all like it
behind those little glass yeah it's like
a smorgasbord but what they call that
thing
I can't with the went out it's like
right on the tip of my tongue there in
the 60s but yeah you could let go in
there and like see anybody
yeah you put your change in your little
automat confection automatic fiction
area I said I knew is a laundromat and I
was like no it's something like that
where you going it's like I want some
key lime pie I'm put like a [ __ ] dime
in there and the Star Trek Star Trek
stuff I know I'm sure they thought that
was very exciting I mean honestly I
still get excited by this [ __ ] like
every now and then we'd like if you're
on a road trip or something then you
stop it like a rest stop and you get one
of them ice cream ones that's like soup
it's like got the big vacuum tube and
it's just like and it's like sucks up
your little [ __ ] one of them like
what are the ice cream cones with like
the [ __ ] ice cream and then it has
like the chocolate shell and not
sometime not nutty buddy or not there
was some pie there was a vacuum wood
house like a it has like a um that's the
bank
remember the bank oh my gosh that's it's
totally different thing there's one it's
and there's one I don't know if it's
there anymore but like many years ago at
the rest stops it's like right between
Orlando and Daytona
they have like a um like it's not good
humor or something or one of those like
big ice cream brands and they have an
ice cream vending machine and it has
like a big freezer at the bottom because
obviously you can't just have like cuz
it'll [ __ ] melt yeah and it has like
this big like tube it looks like a big
vacuum cleaner [ __ ] - and it just
like goes at the little freezer opens
and then it goes and like sucks it up in
there and like drops into your thing and
see it yeah it's super cool I don't know
if it's there anymore but it was there
like a long time ago I was just like
really excited by that I get excited by
simple things but like I said the ones
in Japan like I say you buy booze I
don't know you could buy porn you could
buy old panties you can get [ __ ]
pantyhose no it's not I think Danny's
out of there I think that was it
something like one desk right one thing
they had is a fat a long time that they
made it yeah and they made like a big
deal about it probably never exist
because now everybody over here is like
oh you gotta pay [ __ ]
thing I have once in one location you
hit the news and then they [ __ ] told
us about it and it's probably only
available for like a day there's
probably some [ __ ] yeah and now
we're still talking about 2 years later
well just because it's so weird well
this stuff like that United States you
know I mean you have foreigners [ __ ]
ass crazy questions about the United
States like man has a long time ago and
this [ __ ] wasn't real yeah you know but
that well that's the thing unless you're
there like seeing yourself but I was
reading like this New York Times article
that was about these paraquat murders
and they were talking about all the [ __ ]
that you could get in the vending
machines and they were saying stuff like
kegs of beer that was the most
surprising wit you can get whiskey too
yeah you know dried squid I don't see
the problem
Shinto shrine Oracle I don't see any
problem yeah I grow it up in between
Mississippi and Brazil I have no problem
with underage people drinking I don't
either as long as [ __ ] yeah I mean to be
honest I like I said I don't have kids
ridiculous but I think if I didn't have
genes I would be one of those parents
where look if you want to drink at least
just stay in the house and drink in
Brazil arrived in Brazil you could drink
at any age to give a [ __ ] about that
well did you you were the one that told
me that story about you going somewhere
in Brazil like on the way to work or on
the way to school or something like that
and you like stopped to get coffee or
somebody like that in the morning and
like there's these little little kids
okay smoking smoking and drinking like
in the morning on the way to their [ __ ]
really good work yeah like however old
they were those we liked those are kind
of two banger kids and and kids that
like collect click trash trash gets 500
kids but they had money they'd be out
there [ __ ] smoking cigarettes
they're like 6 7 X amount of 30s yeah
taking big drags off a cigarette hey
chief you know you know what's up man
you know they're eating breakfast and
[ __ ] taking hits of [ __ ] cash ASSA
just [ __ ] ever-closer
kids are hardcore yeah yeah take a shot
say Everclear they're just you just talk
to them you know I was in high school
but just talking to them like they're
any other dude yeah I mean well they're
working people that was rich [ __ ] out
compared to them yes I go down there you
know I'm [ __ ] buy them all [ __ ]
something to eat real quick you know get
some extra
give him some what's called vitaminas
which is like a fruit smoothie him olive
in two minutes cuz I said I was good
yeah ii ii of everybody else one of them
there's like [ __ ] forty cents yeah you
know i mean what does it matter
you know i mean oh thanks chief you know
it's all the same kids all time that's
just pretty that's pretty funny the
thing about yeah it's like
seven-year-old kids just yeah like like
you said like the nineteen thirties like
a russian yeah like a Great Depression
yeah funny
but yeah so if any of any of y'all are
from Japan or been Japan please tell me
what you got in vending machines over
there cuz I'm really curious
didn't have to be dirty panties but just
like you know beer kegs that's
fascinating yeah so just like let me
know but yeah so like I said whoever
this evil [ __ ] is that's been
poisoning [ __ ] and then like leaving it
in a vending machine never been caught
paraquat murders yeah look them up okay
so the next case I want to talk about on
our proliferation of poisoner show is a
female serial killer one of their a few
we don't talk a lot about a lot of
female series but this is one this is
the infamous Nannie Doss we had even
talked about Aileen Wuornos 7 know she
needs her own shower yeah I was I was
just trying to clean it up
the Brazilian kids I was talking about
weren't beggar kids they were those kids
that go down into the intersections and
sell stuff at stoplights they were
selling like big ol jugs of honey
big old wrap big old bags of damn
oranges and tropical fruit sonic I don't
know how that worked out they're working
kids they worked yeah and they were
probably like about seven eight nine
yeah but like I said it was like the 30s
you know they [ __ ] carry themselves
like some little rascal man if they had
a job they had a job yeah and they
probably maybe they didn't have parents
or maybe they were orphans or whatever
they lived they were from the favela
[ __ ] man yeah they're out all day
selling oranges on the right side they
can have a pack of cigarettes if you
want one their sickness mothers not
gonna sell no taking shots of cash and
getting ready for the [ __ ] big day
you know they were there pretty regular
yeah
yourself up for the work day like you do
yeah they were funny like I said
everything I'm not gonna begrudge a kid
that alright so let's talk about nanny
das as I said one of the very rare
female serial killers responsible for
they believe the deaths of at least 11
people starting sometime in the 1920s
and ending in 1954 with her capture she
had several amusing nicknames the best
of which was the giggling granny she was
also called the Lonely Hearts killer the
Black Widow and Liddy Bluebeard hmm
I love this like one newspaper called
her a self-made Widow all right don't
get any ideas
oh we're not married no we're not all
right so nanny was born in November of
1905 in Blue Mountain Alabama
she had one brother and three sisters
now her actual birth name was Nancy
hazel but she became known as nanny that
was her nickname and Doss is actually
the name of her last husband of the many
that she killed damn sounds getting more
and more worried as the show as ghosts
or is that about these [ __ ] women
it's like a poison in there man [ __ ]
dude how many how many shows have we
done about male serial killers killing
women and I don't never tell you don't
get any ideas you don't get easy besides
if you want to be dead that she would
have a long time ago well you're right
about that [ __ ] if I wanted anybody dead
it would happen too long it's all fun
and games all right so now apparently uh
both nanny and her mother could not
stand nannies dad his name is James
he was a very uh one of his role uptight
controlling [ __ ]
he did not want any of the children to
go to school he would rather have them
work on the farm he also didn't want the
female members of the you know of the
children including nanny he would not
allow the girls when they got older he
wouldn't let them wear nice clothes or
wear makeup or anything like that
because he's ugly well he was afraid
that they would get molested by men but
they did anyway they so yes so it's like
they got really I mean nanny got raped
for sure at least once
yeah so it's like that seem greedy here
about this later uh no I'm just saying
that was one thing that happened to her
in her childhood so yeah so these kids
were all working on the farm they didn't
really go to school and [ __ ] like that
now this seems like a significant thing
in light of like a lot of serial killers
have had injuries because when nanny das
was seven years old the family was
taking a train to visit relatives in
southern Alabama and the train stopped
suddenly and nanny hit her head on the
metal bar on the seat in front of her
now for many years afterwards she had
blackouts severe headaches depression
things like that so that may have played
into like some of her I think people
probably although like I said that is a
very common thing that happens to a lot
of serial killers is they have head
injuries as children well you know
anybody who knows me and knows the show
real well I have a serious head injury
that's how I lost a military career
during a motorcycle accident you know I
was in a coma for a few days you know
[ __ ] was [ __ ] up when I got up to
me year year and a half to recover a
head injury will make you [ __ ] mean
it'll give you a hair trigger but it
only lasts a couple years if in my
experience maybe not everybody's the
same well and it might be different when
it happens when you're a kid - because
she was only seven I think it might it
also it definitely for a while kind of
lowered your inhibitions yeah okay um
but that was kind of a bonus for me
during that time cuz I if I saw a girl
and I thought she was cute I immediately
was went up there and just started
working working my [ __ ] magic
and the shipment work magic it is oh
yeah it works it works because you're
all about emotion
you're gonna make it all about emotion
and you talk about how beautiful someone
is and [ __ ] you too loved it Jenny
utilize if I missed out on you missed
out on all that [ __ ] now I just get
yelled yeah just stop like maybe I talk
mad [ __ ] and it was fun you know me but
it wears off yeah cuz you heal up yeah
you know there was kind of like when I
when I was a little kid when I was a kid
there was like a myth that if you had a
head injury that the brain never healed
totally wrong most things will hear yeah
everything heals up and the brain the
human brain is very plastic and prevents
that it will find new ways around yeah
the [ __ ] that's damaged in most cases
unless the damages yet or depending on
what part of the brain it is yeah I'm
still not really good with numbers all
the time and sometimes your memory is
kind of well I'm not I don't want to say
your memories bad across the board
because some things you remember really
well and then other things you don't
remember at all and no passage of time
yeah he has no idea like ebony like a
whole day will go by and he doesn't even
know what time it is I'm like do you
know that it's like 8 o'clock we were
supposed to record the show like four
hours ago and he'll be like surprised
when it gets dark and [ __ ] yeah it's
kind of funny though you know I know
that I do that yeah it doesn't shock me
well like I said it's a you know it's it
is a little bit frustrating to you
because it's like I feel like I have to
tell you the same thing like oh yeah but
like I feel like I have to constantly do
I get that paycheck like once an hour
like I could get that pitch I know like
once an hour I just like hey we were
gonna do that oh yeah forgot I can ever
later you forgot again yeah so I just
keep telling the same thing ever yeah I
would I can't keep my own schedule I I
have to have a secretary yes yeah you
see I don't only have to keep track of
all my [ __ ] I ski pattern holy [ __ ] dude
well I don't have that [ __ ] much [ __ ] to
do
that's true see that's the thing you
don't really do but what's weird is I
can [ __ ] rebuild a car engine like
it's nothing that's right that's what
you like
you have like selectively yeah and I can
do like advanced [ __ ]
yes selective move like you remember
some [ __ ] really good but then other
[ __ ] you can't I can remember old
information super well yeah yeah like if
it like seriously if you if you saw a
movie and I saw a movie like at the same
time and then like years later yeah you
will probably remember the movie better
than I will yeah um but but I mean you
won't remember what happened an hour ago
yeah yeah it's very very weird it ends
on what it is I think true it's kind of
like it's kind of like I'm organizing it
all and prioritizing right you know
based upon selfish needs and desires I
guess I don't think enough probably I
don't think enough but yeah I don't
think about it I just let it roll yeah
that's clear that's that's his whole
thing was just like he just kind of let
let [ __ ] happen yeah I deal with it as
ABS well it's like what else are you
gonna do man it's like I can't fight the
time I can't no one can
I can't fight the earth no one had a
movement of time I can't make that I
can't make the world yield to my desires
nope so I just nobody can I just react
so what happens you know and
artistically spin and artistically do
this and that you know talk about to
kind of get the life that I want ya know
yeah it's like you can't just like lay
down and let the earth roll over you
like no no but I'm interacting with it
you can't yeah but also you can't like
try to like bench it to your will that's
not gonna be better yeah not all the
time sometimes you can you got you got a
no way no when you can you gotta pick
your battles
yeah they say no but so anyway like we
got all we said all that people know
that nany Donna's had a really bad head
injury when she was seven years old and
they she thinks that it might have
contributed to her or later behavior
other people think it might but like I
said that's a very common thing that a
lot of serial killers have is a head
injury in their childhood now also
during her childhood one of her favorite
hobbies was reading her mother's romance
novels and romance magazines and these
magazines she apparently also really
liked the what they
- called a Lonely Hearts columns in the
background which is like people like
personal ads you know now it should be
another era yeah yes now we just have
tender yeah but it was it was like
tinder but like on the page yeah and
people actually wanted to marry you
instead of just like humping you and
leave but like well and like i said i
think people weren't as picky back then
because everyone's but alright so um i
should note that because she really
never had much formal schooling because
her whole dad you know you kids are all
gonna work on the farm but not go to
school and get all that education kind
of crap and dumb occasion edification
yeah um so she actually taught herself
to read using these romance novels so
you know can't be all bad but should be
noted to that i think the romance novels
gave her maybe an unrealistic
expectation of of what relationships
would be like because i think that was a
contributing factor should that happen
later on because she was expecting [ __ ]
to like turn out much different than it
did so nanny first gets married when
she's 16 years old - this guy named
charlie brags who worked with her at a
linen factory now apparently the father
but nanny's father had set this up
because i guess she was trying to he was
trying to get her out of the house or
whatever so these two had only been
dating for four months like i said she
was only 16 and the dad was like yeah
you know marry him and get the [ __ ] out
of here
she wrote like she barely knew the guy
and then like his mom moved in and like
his mom was controlling her life and
controlling his life and as a chance
yeah so yeah they actually ended up
having four kids four daughters from
1923 to 1927 so that's one every year in
case you're counting but nany ended up
being so stressed out by the kids the
husband the interfering mom that she
started drinking heavily came an
alcoholic
drinking and smoking heavily also began
cheating on the husband but the husband
was also cheating on her and would
disappear for days at a time so fair
play there yeah
now in 1927 the two middle daughters
died from what everyone thought was food
poisoning good I don't know if it was or
not I'm kind of doubting it in light of
later events now because of this those
are her daughters yeah because of this
I'm guessing that the husband may be
suspected something because he took
their their firstborn daughter their
oldest daughter whose name was Melvina
and took off now he did leave nanny in
charge of the newborn whose name was
fluorine now after that happened charlie
brags his mother died mm-hmm again
seriously nanny gets a job at a cotton
mill and Charlie brags comes back with
Melvina the oldest daughter in the
summer of 1928 comes back with another
woman who had a kid of her own and like
comes back and like I guess wants to
move back in with Mannix I guess are
they still married that well they were
married at that time but then when he
pulled the prank it's like hey I brought
back this new woman and who also has a
kid but are they still married yeah they
were at that time okay so they came back
and brings his girlfriend but then they
got divorced and then nanny takes the
two remaining girls cuz like I said two
of their daughters had died takes the
two remaining girls back to her mother's
house
now Charlie brags later said that he
took Melvina the oldest daughter and
took off because he was terrified of
nanny so it's possible that she poisoned
those two kids so then she gets married
again in 1929 the second husband's name
was Robert Franklin Harrelson now they
lived in Jacksonville I'm assuming
that's North Carolina although there's
also Jacksonville in Florida so I'm not
really sure now she's married to him a
few months
she still has the two daughters Melvina
and fluorine with her she's only married
to him for a few months and finds out
that he is an alcoholic and that he also
has a criminal record for assault so
special like I said her whole like
romance novel idea of like how shits
gonna turn out it's just not turning out
the way she was expecting you know so
they actually ended up being married 16
years although they weren't together all
that time you know what I'm saying now
at this point Melvina was old enough to
have kids of her own so she has a baby
in 1943 this Olly this gets very
confusing so this is nanny's grandson
his name's Robert Lee Haynes now she had
another baby two years later but he died
very soon after he was like baby
machines that's what I mean these women
just a baby after baby after baby I'm
like oh my god the pill was like so
[ __ ] awesome but like you know I mean
it's like how like how did their vaginas
like survive they did they must have
just been like big baggy purses with
like that although like those damn oh I
like those damn kangaroos [ __ ] you know
what I so wish that humans had pouches I
probably would have had a kid if we
could have it in a pouch was I who was
that kid I think it was Ivor and I still
remember this from like back in the
[ __ ] 80s or 90s that comedian Rita
Rudner cuz I used to watch like a lot of
stand-up on Comedy Central and she was
talking about kangaroos too and she said
I'd have a baby if it would mature in a
handbag I said having to like push it
out of this [ __ ] tiny little space
but honestly though I do think I mean
that's kind of an urban myth that the
more kids that you have like the baggy
er your vagina gets I'm just saying
these people because explain it to him
Jay no because all these women in this
in these stories they just have baby
after baby after baby it's like 12 13 14
babies it's like holy crap holy crap I
mean a lot of them died but Jesus Christ
yeah it was it was the times back in 20s
how are they even alive I don't
understand I don't think I don't think
human bodies were read to like
oh yeah no to [ __ ] do that know my
grandmother I'm a faun my mom sighs my
mom it's my maternal grandmother had
nine kids yeah my maternal grandmother
had eight and they were all [ __ ]
crazy my mom was one of them they were
all yeah I'll agree with you and you
have that many brothers and sit with II
had eight sisters and a brother when you
have that many siblings
it drives you [ __ ] crazy well I don't
know it's like good because like I said
you my mom has seven siblings and
they're all fairly said they fought
constantly
yeah yeah it's weird it's weird though
because I mean I have three siblings
bunch you know my parents had four kids
and we got along like a house on fire we
still do she told me that they fought I
never fought we fought constantly all
ratted each other out because the weird
thing about it and and I thought this
was like pretty normal but apparently
not like other people that have siblings
yeah but I have threesome and there's
like a pretty big age gap I mean you
know what I mean it's like I'm the
oldest and then like I have a brother
that's four years younger I have a
sister that's like seven years younger
then I have another brother that's like
12 years younger
14 years no something like that but we
are all like our personalities are like
really really similar like so much so
that we just like when we're all like
get together which we don't get to do
because we kind of live more apart
that's kind of a shame but we like
finish each other's sentences were so
we're like super similar even though
we're like very far apart in age but I
have heard that that is not very common
most siblings are like I'm only child I
wouldn't know anything about that
yeah yeah I'm kind of like one of them
damn Birds what kind of birds lay all
the eggs in there and then they all
start killing one another don't win this
is that what you did you pushed all the
other ones all the other ones out of the
nest there can be only one yeah right
good all right so as I said nanny
nanny's daughter Melvina has given birth
to a son named Robert Lee Hays Haines in
1943 she also had another baby two years
later but it died now
this baby what ended up happening okay
so Melvina gives birth to the baby and
nanny is there witnessing the birth
oh it's the miracle of life or whatever
now at Melvina is like kind of groggy
and [ __ ] cuz I guess they used to get
pregnant woman ether or whatever and all
the [ __ ] they used to give him cuz you
know for the pain and everything and she
said that she thought she saw her mom
sticking a hatpin into the baby's skull
right so the baby dies and she's like
looking for clarification from her
husband and stuff and they said oh well
nanny told us that the baby was dead or
was born dead and then they said yes she
had like a hatpin in her hand but they
didn't put two and two together I guess
cuz no one saw her do it
except for Melvina and she was like kind
of whacked out from all the medication
that's a weird [ __ ] so yeah so the
doctors were like well they couldn't
figure it out because they asked the
hole that it had made was too small cuz
I guess she like stab you right in the
fontanel or something like that and
that's pretty [ __ ] up so yeah that
yeah right
okay so then that whole thing so Melvina
and her husband broke up Melvina starts
going out with this other guy who was a
soldier
nanny didn't like him so Melvina uh was
visiting her dad like she has a fight
with nanny she goes and visits her dad
and then her son Robert who was only
like a couple years old at the time
died mysteriously while nanny was taking
care of him hmm wonder what could have
happened there so how many is she racked
up now including infants oh she's not
even close to done she's not around
so now this death was ruled as fix eeeh
from unknown causes
two months later nanny collected the
$500 life life insurance plan that she
had taken out on this kid that amounts
to about $7,000 in today's money so she
got $7,000 from this bait from
smothering this baby essentially was
what she did so
1945 apparently the
you know after the Japan surrendered
World War two and everything like that
the guy that nanny was married to that
harrelson dude he got super excited
about it got super drunk and ended up
raping her damn she got really mad about
it no way as you would yeah she finds
his barrel he had like a jar of corn
whiskey that he kept buried in the
backyard cuz I guess he thought he was
like keeping it a secret from people
even though he was a raging drunk all
the time so she's out in her Rose Garden
she finds his whiskey jar so she's like
[ __ ] that guy and she poured a bunch of
rat poison in there and he dropped dead
that same night yeah although he so
alright this is quite a family that's
what I mean crazy [ __ ]
so nanny then meets her third husband
Harley laning and she met him through a
lonely hearts column this was in
Lexington North Carolina three days
later she married him this dude was also
a winner and by that I mean he was a
womanizer and an alcoholic
um so nany was decided she was tired of
putting up with his [ __ ] she didn't kill
him at first but she just started
wandering off and like cheat not even
stuff just because you didn't want to
put up with his crap um but what she did
was that when she was home she would
pretend like she was all like oh she
would be like that so then when he
dropped dead of what the coroner ruled
was heart failure and if you're
listening to the audio podcast I'm
making little air quotes so all the
townspeople do that oh poor poor nanny
or your husband died because they didn't
know about the other ones you know what
I mean because she'd move to a different
town yeah back in those days all you do
just move to the next town and everyone
just thought you were the coolest
[ __ ] ever yeah you could just
like murder mark yeah record keeping
wasn't what it you know the good old
days right that's what that was all
about when you could get away with [ __ ]
Yeah right
so do to go out rob banks do time and
then get out and then move to another
state and become a cop mmhmm yeah
there's all kinds of [ __ ] house what I
mean happen all done yeah so after her
third husband Rob said the couple's
house which had been left to her
sister-in-law mysteriously burned down
the insurance money from this
surprisingly or not went to nanny her
mother-in-law also died in her sleep
mysteriously and she racked up quite a
body count I'm just saying yeah um so
nanny then left North Carolina and went
to stay with her sister Dovie or dovey
I'm not sure how you pronounce that her
sister had some I don't know what was
the matter with her but she was
bedridden she had some kind of ailment
not long after nanny showed up her
sister also died right oh now why did
she kill the [ __ ] nun boy the child
as it was being born she didn't want the
money going to that kid that probably I
guess what it was it seems to me that
what she was doing was a combination of
practical concerns ie I'm trying to get
life insurance money or I don't want
another mouth to feed
run and a thing where the husband's I
think was more a case of they are not
living up to my expectations right and I
thought that everything was gonna be
like a romance novel and every single
one of these dudes has been a drunk or a
womanizer or something else so I think
she just offed them because they
disappointed her so from her point of
view all this shit's practical yeah and
like I said that seems a very common
theme among I mean an alien Hortis is
obviously an exception but pretty much
every female serial killer that you read
about is this type of serial killer they
and they usually kill family members
like and like she did and it's usually
for practical reasons either to get them
out of the way or to get money or did
something like that they don't usually
just kill randos for no reason yeah
that's very very very rare so at this
point nany is looking for another victim
I mean husband so she joins this dating
service called the diamond circle Club
that sounds pretty fancy doesn't sound
like a circle jerk
it may be the help you I have in a
circle be a diamond it's an enigma man
that's like saying it's a round triangle
square banging around all doesn't make a
circle being a dime so she joins this
dating service and then she meets this
guy named Richard L Morton from
Jamestown North Carolina they got
married in 1952 in Kansas now unlike
most of her other husband's he was not a
drunk however like most of her other
husbands he also [ __ ] around on her so
she was planning on poisoning him but
before she did that she poisoned her own
mom in January of 1953 when she came to
live with them three months later she
also poisoned the husband that's how old
is she at this point when all this is
really sure actually she was born in
1905 and this is 1953 okay so she's in
her 40s late 30 late 30s yeah 38 mom was
in her 50s bride yeah 60s
wonder why she killed what she didn't
want the mom hanging around I guess so
cuz the mom said hey I'm gonna come live
with you yeah so yeah so that's another
husband that she's offed and she also
offed her mom then she married her final
husband Samuel Doss and no one's asked
any questions at this point so far okay
I mean you could get away with a lot of
[ __ ] that's crazy so she finally marries
Samuel Doss like I said she's known as
nanny das and that's why this was her
last husband she married him in Tulsa
Oklahoma in June of 1953 he was a
Nazarene minister who had actually lost
his entire family in a tornado in
Arkansas which that's kind of crazy
yeah now one thing that she didn't like
about him was that he started pissing
and moaning about all the romance novels
that she liked oh yeah I didn't want
those around yes so he started like
crying about that you want that female
porn and I guess she did not she did not
take too kindly to his holy assets
about that so in September of that year
which was 1953 he gets taken to the
hospital with symptoms kind of like a
flu hospital said it was probably a
severe digestive tract infection so he
gets treated and released a few days
later but then he died a week after they
let him out of the hospital hmm
apparently nanny had taken out two
insurance policies on him and was kind
of in a hurry to get that chicheng damn
so as soon as like I guess she thought
that he was gonna die in the hospital
and because he didn't she's like
[ __ ] I need to like up this
poisoning game and like okay now because
but because she had rushed yeah and
because he died suddenly the doctor
thought it was suspicious because that
look the doctor said he was sick but
they let him out he was treated and
released so it seemed very weird to him
that he died like a week after they let
him out and they thought he was better
so he actually said well we need an
autopsy and when they did an autopsy
they found a ginormous amount of arsenic
poisoning and then they arrested her so
at her arrest nany das confessed to
killing 4 husbands her mother her sister
her grandson and her mother and lost
yeah although at the time they could
only they only really charged her with
the murder of Samuel das because that
was the what they had the most evidence
for because they had done the autopsy
and everything like that she pled guilty
in 1955 and was sentenced to life in
prison they would not give her the death
penalty because she was a woman yeah she
never did get charged in any of the
other deaths which if you're accounting
it was 10 that she didn't get charged
with she died from leukemia in the
hospital of the Oklahoma State
Penitentiary in 1965 and this is
wonderful right
yeah she's wonderful she just like
[ __ ] tore through the people in a way
she's kind of like like I said it's
like she had practical concerns like she
was trying to get life insurance but
some of the the husband's I feel like
she just married them and thought
everything was gonna be like [ __ ] a
[ __ ] fairy tale and then he turns out
to be like a drunk or racist and she's
just like yeah I bet and she you know I
mean look which I get that
yeah like got daughter-in-laws or having
babies you know [ __ ] that yeah then she
was like [ __ ] that mom comes over nope
[ __ ] that like [ __ ] isn't why anybody
living in her house it just seemed like
she she couldn't take like everybody
that just annoyed her she's just like
well I'm just gonna drop some arsenic
and they're looking you're not taking
over my space yeah that's what she
that's what she was doing this is crazy
it's a crazy one
yeah all right so uh all right so I
think we have two more cases to talk
about but what we are going to do right
now is we will take a short break a
couple commercials no long show maybe a
little video Pookie if we can find her
didn't get her to do something
entertaining deluxe shows that
everybody's always raving about well I'm
telling you it's man October man it's
the best money vacuum in the house it's
like Halloween time it's like fall it's
like everybody loves October so I
thought we would just do like special
edition yet him get away with it you're
gonna let me get away with it all that
but let all y'all get away with how
about Dennis can he get away with it
Dennis Dennis gets away with everything
until they caught him but now these
kotti still get so he's he's locked up
getting away with [ __ ] you getting away
with [ __ ] locked up dinner well I do it
I can you know I get I get stuff you
know yeah he gets stuff for his sexual
problems nice castle Jay okay sex exists
everywhere we have sex in prison you
know I don't really have a problem with
that it's not like it was you don't I'm
glad you're enjoying yourself I'm
retired I'm retired I don't care about
that all right
all right so we're gonna take a short
break right now we'll be back in just a
few minutes
conspiratorial podcasts proudly presents
the strange realities conference and
realities come join us for one day of
presentations on the paranormal of live
music at night featuring Tim banal the
rise and fall of the Flat Earth theory
Joshua Cochin Balian hybrid Lord
Joe d'marie pushing the limits of
reality Timothy Ritter Pennsylvania
Wildman and added to the lineup Marc
Anthony Wyatt cordis legends and UFO
sighting Zach hunt the presentation of
this book unwrapped followed by a live
recording at The Conspirator podcast
more speakers and music acts to be
announced October 9 to 2019 si our
nationís info at WWE a letís conference
calm $40.00 at the door
30 bucks presale
[Music]
hey Pookie what's he doing in a cookie
Oh what you doing yeah you're on video
are you gonna do anything exciting no
you don't feel like it you're just gonna
flop
okay I'm not flop - what's going on
what's going on - baby cookies life
today look at your little tail why are
you such beauty huh dude what's you're
looking at once you're working it I'm
gonna get right up in your face then
give it up on your face yeah don't you
want to get the bubbles no okay
you love true-crime I love true-crime
and I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry baby's case the
Frog Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
all right we are back from the break got
two more cases two covers yeah I can
make it how long so I hope I can make it
I'm toasted well I'm burnt I'm done yeah
well I'm the one who's got a cramp
what's up post yeah that's our little
baby back thing yeah so the next one
we're going to talk about like I said we
have two more cases to talk about now
this guy probably one of the best known
suspected serial killers of the 19th
century this is William Palmer probably
better known as the Rugeley poisoner
also sometimes called the Prince of
poisoners he was an English doctor
although he was actually only convicted
of one murder he was suspected of
several others including four of his own
children no less than Charles Dickens
called William Palmer the greatest
villain that ever stood in the Old
Bailey and I didn't want to know behan
you would think yeah when you got their
literary great he actually like based a
couple characters like on Palmer and
about like some of the investigators
like a bunch of like kind of really
famous like true crime books like I
think there was like an Agatha Christie
they didn't mention Diamond stuff like
that the only thing worse and be like to
have Socrates coming a long time yeah
but yeah so not a lot known about
William Palmer's childhood he was born
in Bruce Lee as I said that is a town in
Staffordshire six of eight children now
his father died when he was 12 years old
and left his mother a substantial sum of
money seventy thousand pounds I did
actually go through and like get the
modern equivalents of that of various
sums in this but I didn't get seventy
thousand pounds but we'll figure it out
later on oh seven thousand pounds that's
probably almost a million million it's
probably a lot yeah because like I said
I went through and did actually the
equivalents of it in modern times but I
forgot to do that one
so they do know that when William Palmer
was 17 years old he actually worked for
an apprentice at a chemist in Liverpool
but was fired after three months because
they thought he was stealing money now
this is something that will kind of
plague him throughout his life after
that he went to London and studied
medicine and actually qualified as a
physician in 1846 so he was actually a
doctor he wasn't like a fake one like
old HH Holmes that like just kind of
half-assedly finished medical men styled
doctor it was this guy was actually
finished medical school as you know is
probably [ __ ] as it was back then
apply leeches okay well we can't do
anything just yeah so yes so he goes and
he actually does get qualified as a
doctor so he then he goes back to
Staffordshire story goes that he meets
this guy named George Abele at a pub in
a town called little Heywood and he
challenges him to a drinking contest
like you do so the guy says sure man
I'll have a drinking contest with you so
they had a drinking contest an hour
later George a Blee has to be carried
home and he died in bed
later that night now this was never
definitively proved as a poisoning but
in light of later events as I said it's
probably pretty likely that William
Palmer had killed this guy especially
since local said that he kind of had the
had the hots for George a Blees wife
right moving in so he goes back to Bruce
Lee to practice as a doctor and he gets
married to a woman named Ann Thornton in
1847 now he had a mother-in-law who's
Tim was also an thorne because Thornton
rather because I guess that it's not
weird it's like I always felt like that
was a dude thing it's like you know
whatever your name is junior but they
used to do that a lot with women too
like the mom would have and
give the daughter the same name as the
mom would they call her a junior no I
don't know they didn't they just gave
him the same name it's like that's just
seems so confusing it's like there's so
many thousands of names in the world
that went out that went out though back
then there's no it's like nobody does
that [ __ ] anymore and like I said that's
probably why because it's super [ __ ]
confusing now the mother-in-law had
actually um got like a big settlement
after her husband had committed suicide
back in 1834 now this was 8,000 pounds
back then and I did look up that's about
823 823 thousand pounds in 2019 money
which is which if you're doing the
calculation that's a [ __ ] ton of money
yeah that's almost a million dollars
yeah in real people money and real
people money
yeah dollars is always real peepers it's
all kind of like if you dollars and
miles like you give a [ __ ] met
Fahrenheit we have no idea and we were
up like I grew up in the 70s and I
remember specifically them teaching us
both the metric system and like it is
essential but it for some reason it
didn't stick even though intellectually
I know that it is easier well metric you
know I kind of had it like relearn
metric when when did the army the Army's
metric yeah yeah so I know meters and
kilometers you know yeah but not not not
temperature just distance well I guess I
mean yeah so that that's the thing it's
like yeah I don't even know so peace
doesn't matter I still have to look it
up no no it's cool about Fahrenheit
what's that Fahrenheit is it's almost
like something from alchemy you know
that yeah it's based upon the
temperature of human blood yeah that's
what sexy [ __ ] when you think about it
yeah like yeah everybody else has their
[ __ ] [ __ ] based upon some boiling
water boiling water freezing water thing
[ __ ] all that what is the temperature in
human blood that's like some [ __ ] we're
gonna base it inspired yeah yeah based
on that yeah on [ __ ] on human blood
because that's some [ __ ] that's like
something
like alchemy and witchcraft and stuff
it's like paranormal I can see that you
know Tama is there that part you're
right it is much cool it's much cooler
even though it makes a lot less sense it
is trying to explain it to a Chinese
woman one time she looked me like I was
[ __ ] crazy as he has based on human
blood temperature he was like why would
you do that you nursed and you're not
gothic like we know it doesn't make any
sense that's what makes looking gothic
but yeah so this woman who had all this
money after cuz her husband and
committed suicide this is his new
mother-in-law mysteriously she dies
two weeks after she came to stay with
William Palmer and his new wife she had
also lent him money reportedly so I
guess he thought he'd get some money
from her then offer so he didn't have to
pay it back although her cause of death
was listed as apoplexy again I'm doing
the air quotes yeah uh now apparently
they get an inheritance him and his wife
get inheritance from the mother-in-law
dying but apparently he was bummed out
because it wasn't as much as he thought
it was going to be so now at this stage
William Palmer and this will be a
repeated thing that happened a lot
throughout his life he was super into
gambling particularly horse racing and
he lost a lot of money at it so as I
said he was almost like borrowing money
from people and [ __ ] like that so he
gets into horse-racing he borrows money
from this guy named Leonard Bladen who
was a man he met at the racetrack Bladen
lent him six hundred pounds which is
about 80,000 pounds and today's money
but um later died in horrible agonizing
pain in May of the 1850 now it also
turned out that he didn't have any money
on him even though he had apparently won
a bunch just at the races and also all
of his bedding books which said like you
know what who he had London lent money
to and stuff like that those were also
missing so you can probably guess where
that [ __ ] went now again the cause of
death I guess because they didn't
suspect poisoning was given as injury of
the hip joint five or six months abscess
in the
that's what it said on his death
certificate so had an abscess in his
pelvis which that could that could mean
a lot of things do with your groin
I was thinking Ryan yes yeah I don't
they're talking about well I don't know
it doesn't really matter because I'm
pretty sure this [ __ ] was
poisoned yeah so William Palmer has a
son named William Brooks Palmer born in
either 1848 or 1850 they're not really
sure now he didn't kill this kid he
actually ended up out living the dead
however William and his wife had four
more children and all of these children
died in infancy yeah cause of death for
all of these was listed as again air
quotes convulsions yeah Elizabeth Palmer
died on 6th of January 1851 two and a
half months old
Henry Palmer died on 6 January 1852 bout
a month old
Frank Palmer died on December 19th 1852
only seven hours after he was born now
no one thought and he thought that much
about it I mean it's the [ __ ] 1850s
like babies died all the time so no one
thought it was terribly suspicious so no
one really thought about him having done
that to the kids until later on like
after he got convicted in 1856 now by
1854 he is like big-time in debt because
like I said he was big horse racing he
lost a lot of money so when he started
doing was forging his mom's signature on
various things so he could like pay off
creditors he took out a life insurance
policy on his wife always a red flag
later yeah
and he paid the premium was 750 pounds
which in today is 82 580 2500 pounds and
the policy was 13,000 pounds which is
about 1.5 million pounds and then his
wife died conveniently on September 29th
1854
she was only 27 years old it's weird
that deer in the 1800s there was a lot
of these poisoning people scams for this
oh yeah there's a lots and lots of
mm-hmm that was just something you know
that was like part of the culture almost
well the weird thing about it and I was
just like reading cuz I was like
skimming through this uh this poisons
book here earlier in preparation for the
show
and you know there's like some poisons
like arsenic and strychnine and stuff
like that have like kind of weird like
cute little nicknames
about I can't remember what the one like
there's one in French that they call one
poison where it's like [ __ ] where it
has to do with like you know you wanted
inheritance and someone's in your way
yeah of getting it they call it like it
succession powder that's what it
succession powder because that's what
you used when you when someone was gonna
get your inheritance
yeah so it's like it was that common
that they had like a cute like nickname
for it and a lot of poisons have that
because that was like super [ __ ]
common I mean not only like you know
going back to [ __ ] ancient Roman
times where people were like poison and
people left them right like to get into
the throne or whatever but it's like
particularly into Victorian times man if
you had like a few million pounds like
coming to you and someone else was in
your way or you die quicker yeah well
because and the thing is people died all
the time of various maladies and a lot
of poisons kind of mimic those symptoms
yeah and I think that's why like a lot
of these poisoners got away with it so
long like this dude William Palmer
presumably killed his wife she was 27
years old to get the life insurance
policy her cause of death was listed as
cholera because at the time there was
like a huge epidemic of cholera if that
meant that part of Great Britain said no
one thought no one thought anything
about it thinking off their young wives
yeah so like people were dropping like
flies all the time and like I said the
infant mortality rate was very high so
it's like people dying like a bunch of
your kids dying and [ __ ] like that no
one would say boo yeah you know because
it wasn't that unusual sadly this is a
spooky world back then it was very that
haunted house and Disney World [ __ ]
made sense now
morale yeah so his next little scam
because apparently this dude is like
gambling his whole [ __ ] life away
because he's getting like all these life
insurance you know he's getting all this
money but he's still like [ __ ]
blowing at all but he's still like super
in debt he had two particular creditors
that were like kind of barking on his
snorkel for money he owed like something
like 32,000 pounds to the both of them
they were actually going to go like talk
to his mother about it because they had
heard that he was like forging his
mother's signature or whatnot then she's
spending his money on just horse racing
it seemed like just horse racing just
just pissing it away pissing it away and
[ __ ] gambling it away yeah that
seemed like mostly what it was I wonder
if he was more of a gambling addict or a
serial killer I'm more but to me it
seems like more because it seemed like
he just killed people to get money so
more like a gambling addict yeah yeah
and it's like cuz he had all these debts
because and I think the reason that he
killed four of his kids now one of his
kids survived and actually outlived him
but that was his first son but the other
four I mean he killed him when they were
only a few months old probably because
he's thought oh we can't afford them
yeah you know he needs one anyway yeah
that's probably what he thought so like
I said it was it seemed like a
completely practical run concern where
yeah he's got a kid he doesn't need
another one yeah it's like look we don't
need any more right yeah so then he
tries to take out a life insurance
policy on his brother Walter for eighty
four thousand pounds and kills brother
however like there was no company that
would give him a policy for that amount
because that's a lot of money and I
guess they can't cross-reference I can't
check the other companies I don't guess
they could back that cuz I would check
this [ __ ] out you know I mean
you'd be like well how many other
policies have you won yeah you know I
mean if you collect it on a bunch of
policies I given you a policy well we
thank you it seems like it seems like
very easy back then I don't think you
could get away with this nowadays unless
you were super super clever like it
seems like back then you could just get
a [ __ ] insurance policy on anybody
there was nothing computer
see that's what I mean jack anything
like you can just forged signatures
willy-nilly you could like [ __ ] you
could take out insurance policies on
people that didn't even know that you
had one on them right like that's pretty
creepy yeah and also hard to prove
identity back then too right it's like
nobody got driver's licenses it was like
no [ __ ] so you got in trouble you
could just assume another identity right
and a lot of people did yeah so he
finally gets this one insurance company
that would give him like a much smaller
one they said they'd give him a fourteen
thousand pound policy if he paid like
seven hundred and eighty pounds now what
ended up happening was his brother was
an alcoholic so what William Palmer
started doing was bringing his brother
like a bottle of gin a day and a bottle
of brandy a day which was supposedly
adulterated with various substances hmm
and his brother ended up dying in August
of 1855 but the insurance company would
not pay because they found out that he
had also been trying to take out ten
thousand pounds of insurance on this guy
that had worked for him which seemed a
little fishy to them so they hired a
couple people to go investigate yeah um
so that whole thing was going on they
had that whole inquiry now at this time
he gets involved in kind of an
extramarital affair well I guess it
wasn't because his wife was dead because
he killed her right yes but he starts
yeah he starts screwing around with his
housemaid whose name was eliza farm and
she ended up having a baby named Alfred
so he knocks that well baby off I don't
know if he did actually um but yes so he
at this point he's running up like now
he has an illegitimate kid he has this
like you know this mistress or whatever
so then he decides that he is going to
to get money he's gonna kill his friend
who's name is John Cooke
now John Cooke was had been kind of a
sickly dude
he had a really big fortune that he had
inherited from his family or whatever of
12,000 pounds which as I said was a lot
of money back then so they both of them
go to this horse race in November of
nineteen of 1855 rather now cook won
3,000 pounds that day and Palmer lost
and I love the name of the horses that
they bet on like the winning horse was
named Polestar which is cool name the
one that William Palmer been on that
Lawson was called the chicken the
chicken the horse's name was the chicken
dance what the [ __ ] kind of name is that
for a [ __ ] racehorse oh this look
like a chicken I guess so after that
they go to this pub to like have a
celebration for I mean presumably cook
is celebrating cuz he won Palmer's not
celebrating because he lost but this
whole time I guess prior to this Palmer
had been kind of giving him drinks that
already had poison in it so he they go
to this pub he buys him some gin and he
complained and said that it was like
burning his throat like he thought there
was something in it
so William Palmer makes this big deal on
the pub it's like oh look I didn't put
anything in there you know it's fine
just like his friend was suspicious you
know what I mean as you would be now
after this whole affair cook gets really
sick and he says to two friends
reportedly and they like testified at
the later trial and everything like that
he said quote I believe that damn Palmer
has been dosing me so yeah so then they
go back to Rugeley
cook gets a room at the 10th this hotel
cup it's Talbot arms now at this point
Palmer's kind of getting desperate
because he had gotten this letter from a
creditor who said I'm gonna go to your
mom it's like I know you've been like
forging her signature and you're gonna
get in big trouble now the next day like
Palmer went to the racetrack again to
try to win some money back and he lost
again so he lost like a whole bunch of
money so Palmer asked cook to go out
again for a drink with him on November
17th
and again cook got really really
SiC so then he like he takes the guy
back to the hotel and he brings him
another bottle of gin this other girl
that was there she was like a
chambermaid she took a sip of the gin
and she also got super sick so there
must have been like a really lot of
poison in there yes
kook drank the rest of the gin and got
super see was just like vomiting and
everything like that then Palmer goes to
the racetrack on the next day collects
all of kooks winnings which were 1200
pounds which is about 128 thousand
pounds of today's money he then goes to
a [ __ ] place and buys three grains of
strychnine puts them into two pills and
gives them to cook and then cook died on
to the 21st of November apparently in
horrible agony screaming about how he
was suffocating damn now after this
whole there was this whole thing like
after this where there was some
suspicion that he had done something to
him but then he was able to convince
like this doctor who was 80 years old to
do the death certificate and list the
cause of death is apoplexy right so he
was able to do that he got rid of like
cooks bedding books and all the stuff
where he said where he had loaned money
and how much money he had won and stuff
like that so there was that whole thing
then they were going to do a [ __ ] so
they do a [ __ ] a post-mortem and they
let [ __ ] Palmer like are they or they
let him into like the the post-mortem or
whatever like it was in the hotel where
they were doing like the thing and
they're like they let him take the there
was a jar with like all the dudes
stomach contents in it and he like took
him he's like I'll keep these somewhere
safe and [ __ ] like that and he took you
know what I mean so there was like all
these shenanigans everybody was like
drinking it was just like this
ridiculous kind of crap then William
Palmer actually tried to bribe the
coroner he sent him like a ten pound
note and he said hey can you write like
natural causes
not the [ __ ] desert
was like all this kind of like sugary I
guess but it's like so the guy that was
like doing the autopsy he said well he
didn't find any evidence of poison I
mean obviously because the stomach
contents were gone which is probably
because it was strychnine so that's
probably where this poison would have
been but he said okay well I didn't find
any evidence of poison but I think the
dude was poisoned right so now they did
an inquest and the jury actually agreed
with that guy and said yeah we think he
was probably poisoned too and that it
was probably William Palmer cause it's
cuz sketchy as [ __ ] so he actually did
so William Palmer actually did get
charged with the murder and with forgery
because a creditor came forward and told
him about the whole fortune his mom's
signature thing
so he gets detained at Stafford jail at
first he like threatened to go on a
hunger strike for whatever reason but
they said no we'll just force-feed you
so then he just said okay we'll forget
it so so they so they take the they
moved the trial to the Old Bailey
because they said there was either he
couldn't get a fair trial and
Staffordshire because everyone had heard
about it or everyone thought he was a
swell guy in Staffordshire and they were
afraid that they wouldn't get a guilty
verdict one of those two reasons so they
moved it to London at the Old Bailey now
yes so the Home Secretary he says okay
well we need to exhume the bodies of
Walter Palmer who was Williams brother
and an his wife and reexamined them
because now they're suspecting that they
had been poisoned as well with uh his
wife had been dead for how long um it
hadn't been that long it was only like a
year or two
well [ __ ] she'd be rotting which well
the front yet um now Walter was actually
too decomposed to get anything from but
they did find a traces of poison in all
of his wife's organs so there we go
now there was some you know a bunch of
legal [ __ ] it's like you know one of
the [ __ ]
you know one of the guys of things said
he thought that dude was innocent and
there's all this other kind of crap
going on
so all this other stuff kind of came out
at the trial this one guy or this one
woman said that when Cooke was dying
that he had actually came out and said
that he that William Palmer had killed
him
some people had seen William Palmer
purchasing the strychnine the chemist
that had sold him it said yes I did sell
him the strychnine and I didn't write it
in my little because they're supposed to
keep it regulative like everybody that
buys poison and he didn't write it down
why not he said what no I don't know he
just didn't write it down there was
actually another chemist named Charles
Roberts who said the same thing he's
like yeah I sold that guy strychnine too
and I also neglected to write it in my
book so the e is so there was all this
other kind of crap now again there's
like you know the doctor that said it
was natural causes they said oh that
guy's too old and it's like that was all
the thing with the [ __ ] the [ __ ] um
you know the him like trying to bribe
one of the dudes into saying natural
causes and [ __ ] like that in the end
after all the shekinah reese shenanigans
and whatnot the jury thought that yeah
that he probably totally did it now they
could only get him on one of the deaths
the death of cook because they had the
most evidence for that even though they
had evidence like they like I said they
examined his wife's body and they found
like extensive like evidence of poison
in all of her organs but I guess it had
been so long ago that blah-dee-blah
so he only ended up getting convicted of
one murder that of his friend cook but
he assisted one murders enough so they
sentenced him to hang now back then they
had public hangings yeah thirty thousand
people came out to Stafford prison on
June 14 1856 to see his public hanging
this I found very funny reportedly as
William Palmer stepped onto the gallows
he said to have looked at the trapdoor
and exclaimed are you sure it's safe
[Laughter]
thought was very funny yeah um yeah so
his mom there was a big thing about
because they even like made a
documentary or film later on of this
quote after he was hanged
she made the quote they have hanged my
saintly Billy she said no and there was
it like even a documentary or film about
him that was called that
here's another rather gruesome thing and
oh the 19th century you guys there was
an X there was a newspaper after the
execution and the and the article read
it is stated that the rope that hanged
Palmer is selling at five shillings per
inch the seller is a man from Dudley
where Smith the hangman resides the
interesting relic it is said meets with
ready purchasers yes the rope has also
been selling extensively in England it
is said and of course is being spun as
the demand for it increases so make it
more robust yelling I don't know how
much that is in today's money it's like
you know it's yeah that's like that's
like the old money like before the
nineteen seventies so you know there's
still like a lot would he have been
convicted nowadays on that evidence
probably not but the thing is if he had
tried to pull this [ __ ] nowadays they
would have had a lot more forensic so
that's what I mean and it really does
seem like hey life insurance but you
change it it's like you know what I mean
and then people are drinking with him
and then they turn up dead and he's
making jokes about oh I didn't put
anything in your drink a statistical
probabilities of getting all those damn
life insurance policies right there's
enough to [ __ ] put you in the damn
good I mean danam in the electric chair
yeah
stop it so I mean there are some people
that have argued that there wasn't
enough I don't think anyone's argument
that he was innocent it's just that
there wasn't enough evidence sticking
video is guilty but I think pretty much
everybody knew it was kind of like a
situation like nanny das where it's just
kind of like to me dude only so many
dead people can turn up around you
before people start thinking that that's
you you know what I'm saying so yeah
again William Palmer probably one of the
most fame
poisoners of the 19th century and there
is a wax figure of him and the chamber
of horrors at Madame Tussauds which I
have seen actually um and also it is
thought that the that the phrase what's
your poison comes from this like then
that's where it stemmed from so you know
in case you ever wanted to know like I
said there's been like a bunch of other
it was a mention mention of him in the
Sherlock Holmes story The Adventures of
the speckled band and all this other
kind of stuff they've made movies and
mentions of him in all kinds of
literature and [ __ ] like that so that's
the case of William Palmer we're gonna
do one more also now the last case I
want to talk about here's another female
serial killer Mary and cotton this is
also from the 19th century even though
she was only convicted of one murder she
is suspected of murdering as many as 21
people including several of her
husband's and a whole [ __ ] ton of her
own children so what year was this she
was actually born in 1832 okay so going
back to the tour in there yeah so this
is like similar to those Disney Land
haunted house [ __ ] yeah yeah she was
actually born Mary Ann Robson on
Halloween of 1832 in lo Moore's Lee in
Sunderland now they don't know a great
deal again about her childhood they do
know that when she was 8 years old
she moved with her family to this
village called Merton in County Durham
reports from the time said that she was
actually a very normal child they said
she was very clean and tidy she was
average intelligence went to school
regularly should nothing unusual in the
slightest now
not too long after they moved to this
particular village her dad who was a
worked in a coal mine fell 150 feet to
his death down a mine shaft this was in
1842 now grimly her father's body was
actually taken to the house
in a bag that said that had a stamp on
it that said property of the South pet
and coal company yeah classy keep it
classy also another shitty thing was
that the house they were living in was
owned by the coal mine so now that the
guy was dead they had you they had to
get the [ __ ] out the kids had to get the
[ __ ] out right so that's nice now a year
after that her mom remarried to a guy
named George Stott who was also a miner
now at this stage Marianne is 16 years
old and she actually left home to become
a nurse like in this other guys house
and then later on like she came back to
her stepfather and mother's house and
studied to be a dressmaker now in 1852
when she was 20 years old
Marianne married her first husband whose
name was William Mowbray he was a
Collier Lea Collier II laborer at
Newcastle upon Tyne now apparently they
had around this time period they had
four or five four or five children which
who died young or died in infancy but
none of the deaths were registered now
the law was that you were supposed to
report deaths of children or of anyone
but the law was not super stringently
enforced until later on so no one is
quite sure what happened there it could
be that she killed those kids as well
now the only birth that was registered
at around this time of her and her
husband was the daughter that they had
whose name was Margaret Jane and she was
born in 1856 now then they moved back to
North East England and then they had
another daughter named Isabella who was
born in 1858 now their first daughter
Margaret Jane died in 1860 again
mysterious causes they had another
daughter who they also named Margaret
Jane after the ones who had just died
she was born in 1861 then they had a son
named John Robert William born in 1863
but a year later he died of and again
I'm doing the air
Quotes gastric fever which is what
pretty much all of the people around
this woman died of so you can see where
this is going
now William the husband he died of an
intestinal disorder in January of 1865
now obviously just like any good
poisoner
she had ensured the lives of her husband
and children so for the husband she got
35 pounds which is about 3,200 pounds in
today's money which was about six months
wages for a laborer back then so not too
bad
she also got two pounds five shillings
for the son that died now not too long
after the death of her first husband she
moves to Siem Harbor in County Durham
and then starts up a relationship with
this guy named Joseph natural I guess is
how you pronounce his name now around
the time that she was screwing around
with this guy her daughter Margaret Jane
and this is the second Margaret Jane as
I said because the first Margaret Jane
had already died this one also died
presumably of typhus fever she was
three-and-a-half years old so she so
Mary Anne goes back to Sunderland and
gets a job as a nurse now she sends her
kid Isabella who's still alive at this
point to go live with her mom now one of
the patients at this infirmary that she
worked at was named George ward and they
struck up a relationship and they ended
up getting married in 1865 now he was
pretty sickly through their entire
marriage and ended up dying in October
of 1866 after a long illness and they
could the wikipedia page says
characterized by paralysis and
intestinal problems the cause of death
was listed as English cholera in or
typhoid so what's the pattern here she's
meeting these guys it's not really
working out right yeah so she kills the
guy and the kids that she has with him
usually so she and gets the insurance
money gets the insurance and then she
reboots it and does it again yeah is she
looking for the perfect
relationship that was she had the same
kind of thing as nanny das had I feel
like Nannie Doss like I said had the
whole practicality thing like I'm gonna
kill people and get the insurance money
or I'm gonna kill kids because they're
too expensive but she also seemed to
have a thing where she was looking for
something that she could never obtain
whereas I feel like Maryanne cotton was
just more like well I'm just gonna try
and get the money right kind of thing I
don't think she had she didn't seem to
have any like weird illusions about
romance or anything like yeah and she
didn't have any any connection to her
own kids
not really right she kills him by about
what she ended up killing most of them
and about what age all ages various okay
yeah she gets sick of him I guess so
yeah so she killed the second husband to
george ward and got and she also
collected the insurance money
now the next husband was named James
Robinson now he was actually a recent
widow widower rather his wife Hannah had
recently died and Maryann went to his
house to work as a housekeeper in
November of 1866 now he had had James
had had a baby with his former wife who
had just died now the baby died of
gastric fever mm-hmm um and he ended up
being really sad and so he struck up a
relationship with Mary Ann who was the
housekeeper so she was poisoning the
baby yeah she poisons his baby that was
his only yeah I mean you know like I
said they didn't prove it but it just
seemed kind of weird that everywhere she
went like babies and husbands are
dropping dead rah so she gets pregnant
now Mary Ann's mom she got hepatitis and
now she lived in another town so I don't
I don't think that Mary Ann gave her
hepatitis however I know what hepatitis
is that's what I mean but Mary Ann went
to visit her mom because she had
hepatitis and then her mom seemed to be
getting better but then starts getting
stomachaches yeah and then died in 1867
she
euthanized only nine days after Maryann
got there my mom was only 54 years old
yeah so yes she have an insurance policy
on her probably either that or she was
just like sick of her bitching I don't
know you that if she thought it was
euthanasia maybe that's what it wasn't
maybe she thought she was suffering and
it's like well I'll just put her out of
her misery or something like that yeah
now in 1867 um you know the same year
that her mom died her Marion stepfather
George Scott married a neighbor named
paying a Paley now Marianne still had a
daughter named Isabella from her first
husband who was still alive however she
comes back to live in this particular
household and ends up dying as did two
of a couple of other children like the
the third husband had some other
children two of his other children died
as well as taking out all competition
right like and this was just like in the
period of in a period of a few weeks in
1860 yeah addicted to killing people
[ __ ] crazy
yeah she's [ __ ] nuts so she ended up
getting a life insurance but only on her
own daughter because the other kids
weren't her so she didn't get anything
from that like you said I guess it was
probably just like competition like for
the husband's attention and she just
thinks she could kill anybody get away
with it yeah maybe that's what it is so
now Mary Ann is getting well yeah she
did get away with a fervor a long time
so Mary Ann marries him in August of
1867 because apparently he wasn't
suspicious of all these [ __ ] yeah
people dying around her now they had a
kid named Margaret Isabella she was born
in November of 1867 but died in February
of 1868 so she knocks the baby off good
- yeah wow that's weird
oh I wonder why that's what I mean it's
like these female serial killers that do
a lot of them seem to be of this type
and it's just it seems to me that to be
like either a practical type of thing or
a weird she gets sick of the kid she
doesn't want to be a mom so she her like
an angel of death type of thing I think
she I think what it is is that she gets
sick of the kids she doesn't want to be
a mom maybe yeah maybe that's what it's
so she wants to go back to being kind of
like a bride yeah yeah just hurt and the
guy well you have to think do it he she
gets sick of him so she knocks his ass
yeah I mean you have to think too at the
time that you know divorce was very
difficult um you know birth control was
very difficult to obtain you couldn't
get abortions easily you know what I
mean so like you end up married to some
douche it's like you just saw her
pregnant all the time and having all
these babies all the time and I like
this guy and you want out of situation
and you can't really get out so in a way
like it's not it's not excusing it I'm
just saying you understand that how it
could happen but she is choosing these
guys see so that's apparently yeah and
then like those are her kids yeah you
know I mean and they're big enough to
make a connection with them yeah so
knocking him off I mean come on yeah
it's that cold [ __ ] bloody well in
yeah and I was thinking about like the
[ __ ] Nannie Doss case they were
talking about to where she was like
stuck a [ __ ] hat pin at the baby's
top of the baby's head yeah that was
even her baby yeah it was her no it was
her grand baby
it was her grand everything on her big
yeah crazy she's didn't want that baby
around it living in our house yeah this
is some [ __ ] weird-ass people man
that's what I mean it's like I'm weird
yeah so all right so the first two the
first kid that they had that she had was
a third husband died after only a few
months now they had a second one named
George who was born in June of 1869 but
at this point like the third husband is
getting kind of suspicious because
Maryann kept like saying hey you should
really take out a life insurance policy
hey wanna go down there and do that what
are you gonna do that you know I mean
she was like kind of nagging about it so
he was getting a little suspicious also
he found out that she had run up a bunch
of debt behind his back and had taken 50
pounds from him that he she was supposed
to put into the bank so he got really
pissed off about it also found out
she had been trying to talk his older
kids into like like pawning all of their
like a bunch of stuff that was in the
house and then she was pocketing the
money so he actually threw her out and
he kept their son George now at this
point Mary Ann is homeless so she is
kind of desperate she has a friend named
Margaret and Margaret introduces her to
her brother Frederick who was a recent
widow um
now at this stage so she moves in on
Frederick and then kills Margaret the
sister yeah because she died from an
undetermined stomach ailment and then
Mary Anne was all like getting up cozy
on Frederick and then she gets pregnant
again this is her twelfth pregnancy in
case you were accounting so Mary Ann and
does she killed her friend to steal the
brotherbrother yeah and I guess she
killed the Frigg because she wanted her
out of the house yeah because the sister
had been staying in the house because
Frederick was his wife had just died and
he had a couple kids so the sister was
like they're helping him take care of
the kids she's trying to nest down again
she gets rid of the [ __ ] female so
she can have that house for herself yeah
and then gets pregnant again and you
know what's gonna happen yeah he's gonna
kill that kid and then she's gonna kill
that man yeah yeah yeah so this [ __ ] is
a [ __ ] nut yeah [ __ ] serious [ __ ]
wingnut yeah so Mary Anne and Frederick
get married in September of 1870 now at
this point I don't think that her
divorce like either his divorce I'm a
finalist like his wife died but I think
she he she was still married to her last
husband cuz she didn't kill the the last
husband he kicked her out right so she
was technically still married to him
right but she married this fourth dude
anyway you do this technically bigamy
you could do that back then there was a
way didn't Kent check the records too
much so they had a son named Robert in
1871 then Mary Ann finds out that a guy
that she had been [ __ ]
before Joseph Nattrass like in-between
her first and second husband I think now
he was living not that far away and he
was no longer married he's available so
she calls shoot like not called him up
she like she sends up a booty call yeah
in the 19th century
I guess she like sent him a letter and
it took like two weeks or whatever but
yes she's like hey wanna like you know
light that back up and he's like yeah
sure so she gets the whole family like
her new husband and [ __ ] like to move
closer to him so she can like go over
there and bang him I guess now the
fourth husband died she knocked if she
knocks his ass off as well so she got
life insurance policy and what about the
bay there she killed the baby I don't
think she killed that baby okay so after
that the dude she'd been knocking off on
the side that she'd been sleeping with
on the side he moved in to her house as
a lodger okay and then she gets a job as
a nurse from for this guy who was like
he was like some kind of military
officer and he had had smallpox and he
was like recovering any need in home
nurses she went there and worked for him
and it should not be surprising to the
she'd also she got pregnant from that
guy this is her 13th pregnancy she's
also just straight up huh yes right up
up yeah what it is is I think she's
seeing dollar signs yeah bigger better
lifestyles so she's probably thinking
well have the kid with this [ __ ]
smallpox officer get him to sign over
all his [ __ ] to me
yeah and I'll knock him and this kid off
and I'll have all his stuff yeah and
I'll go back to the other one yeah but
she's gonna end up killing that one too
you know how she is yeah she just kills
everybody yeah so yeah so like I said
she's got this guy that was she was
cheating on her white on her husband
with and it's like he moved in and then
she's cheating on him with another guy
and she's got pregnant again then it
ends up that
Frederick Jr who was the son that she
had with the fourth husband I'm losing
track of all the husbands he died in
March of 1972 and then the baby Robert
also died a little bit after that then
the dude that naturist dude that she'd
been like the first guy that she'd been
having an affair with then he died uh
coincidentally just after he had put
Mary Ann in as well right yeah so yeah
so he died yeah so she's doing yeah
she's trying to she's trying to [ __ ]
profit off yeah well she is yeah it's
working yeah now one of her husband's is
still alive at this point and this was
what ended up getting her caught because
apparently she's asked by this guy he's
like some kind of official in the parish
his name's Thomas Reilly he says hey
there's a woman in the parish and she
has smallpox you know if she was that
Mary Ann was a nurse it's like can you
come and like take care of her for some
reason
Mary Ann says to this guy that she's
like Charles Edward he was uh I think
was the son that she had with the last
husband that he was in the way and that
he should be sent to a workhouse right
who I guess I think this is the son
this is one of her sons all right with
one of the husbands so she's like can I
send him to a workhouse coz it like I
can't take this job coz I have to take
care of this kid or something she had
like some kind of excuse like that so um
so the parish official is like well yeah
but you have to be there like you have
to come you know with it and like do you
have to do all this [ __ ] and then she
said to him um well the boys really sick
anyway and she said quote I won't be
troubled long he'll go like all the rest
of the Cotton's like she had killed them
all and she's oh he'll die sooner or
later I'm not gonna worry about it so
she basically said that too like this
[ __ ] Rando right five days later the
kid was dead and she told Riley as much
she's like yeah he died just like I said
now Riley got suspicious he went to the
police
and said hey don't give a death
certificate of that you guys need to do
an autopsy or whatever you did you do
because I think she did something to him
because he said about the weird [ __ ] she
had said now after the kid died it's
like she didn't go to the doctor she
shouldn't go through she goes right to
the insurance office right but since a
death certificate had been delayed
because that guy go to the police they
said well look we can't give you like
the money until you have a death
certificate and so they had an inquest
now at the inquest they ruled that the
death was from natural causes Marianne
said that she had given him like that he
had been sickly and that she had given
him arrowroot and then she made up this
story about the parish official it's
like oh he's just saying making up those
things about me because he hit on me and
I said no so he's just like making me
look like a bad guy right now but at
this point though like a bunch of the
media in the area had kind of picked up
on the story and then they started
looking into her background and they
said hey this woman's been like moving
all over the area and her husbands and
children are dying at every turn so
maybe you guys should like look into
this so eventually they have this doctor
who comes in and he had done an autopsy
on the son that had died and found
arsenic so when they said they arrested
her now she got only got charged with
that one murder and actually while she
was on trial I think she gave birth to
her 13th kid well 11 of them were dead
yeah only day was she and then she
erases them yeah pretty much
now there was um some thing at the trial
like she did eventually go to trial just
for that one murder of Charles cotton
now there was like a big problem was
like the [ __ ] the prosecution and all
this other kind of [ __ ] but that was
eventually sorted out the defense's
argument was that Charles had actually
not been poisoned but that he had died
from the green wallpaper because and
actually in this book right here
he goes a long way into like there was
this wallpaper that was became very
popular in the 19th century that was
like this beautiful shade of green and
it had arsenic in it and when it got
damp and like sometimes the arsenic
would leach out and it could like how it
was enough to like kill some people so
that was the defense's argument that the
wallpaper had actually killed the kid
and that he hadn't been murdered on
purpose so there was like a whole thing
there now it should be said that the
jury did not buy this especially after
they kind of went into like her history
they're like look there's a little
suspicious that she's going all over
these different towns she's marrying all
these people all these people are having
and they're all from the same thing
quote unquote gastric fever because what
she was using arsenic that you know the
the symptoms of that like mimic you know
something like that something some kind
of stomach ailment or a stomach
complaint so she actually did end up
getting convicted now Leah no nanny das
actually got off because she was a woman
she didn't get the death penalty however
Marianne cotton got no such comfort she
actually hanged and this is an American
case right no British no British British
yeah they hanged her in March of 1873
and actually that the Rope didn't break
her neck it she actually strangled to
death and it took like three minutes and
some have speculated that somebody who
bragged the Rope too short on purpose
yeah so she would suffer more yeah so I
you know I don't know if that's true or
not but some people have said that yeah
[ __ ]
so um of Marion's 13 children that she
gave birth to only two lived right like
she killed all the other ones and she
killed three of her four husbands and
may have killed several other people as
well because like I said she kind of
killed her mom yeah she killed her mom
and you know various other people to her
mother not mother-in-law to write know
that that was the other ones kind of
similar occasion yeah so if you live in
the UK I'm sure you probably saw in 2015
ITV did a two-part television drama
called Dark Angel which was about the
Mary Ann cotton case because she said it
was apparently a lot better known over
there than she is here but I just found
her case really fascinating and you know
so that'll be that case talking about
all the poisoners today what do you
think about that Dennis oh so now you're
calling Dennis I tell it : Dennis Lee
well you've just been sitting there not
saying anything you got to contribute to
the show some time you have time forgot
about data yeah just like all India's
mojito or whatever get first-hand
something it's not only men that have
sexual problems with women sometime so
sexual problems yes sure they have
children and then they don't want the
children that did knock children off and
you know how it is I guess yeah all
right so this is probably all right this
is probably gonna load it you're trying
to get me to [ __ ] do Dennis just on
the blue out of the blue just man dude
you got to do something I've been like
you're like reading all the notes in a
long night doing this [ __ ] this show
well I know yeah it's a long show and
welcome to my world man to man
alright so hope you guys enjoyed this
extra-long variety show that various
bone this is well yeah this is like a
topic that I always found really
interesting I have like a bunch of books
benches and everything like that so I
hope you guys had as much fun as we did
and remember if you like the show like
share subscribe on all your social media
if you'd like to financially supports
show of course you can go to our patreon
page or our blog where we have a button
to a PayPal account where you can give a
one-time donation he's just like
distracting face it out of like no I was
thinking about the button go to bed I
was thinking about the button the button
the button that you press that goes to
pay money I go yeah
press that button yeah press that one
goes right to a pen that goes right to
Jenny goes Jenny and Jenny and she uses
it to pay bills
yeah and that's about it it'll come
Jenny don't worry that'll do it for
episode a hundred and sixty four we will
see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]